learn how to get AI to do the coding for
you in this course you will use chat GPT
to build interactive database powered
projects you'll learn how to write
effective prompts and debug and refine
your code with the help of Ai No coding
experience needed Gil Hernandez teaches
this course imagine waking up tomorrow
as a web developer what would you want
to build it turns out that with AI tools
like CPT you're already a developer
regardless of your experience
if you know how to work with them
welcome to a different kind of coding
course that's less about the intricacies
of coding and more about building
experimenting and realizing your ideas
even without coding knowhow it's your
fast lane towards getting the coding
superpower in this course you'll use
HTML CSS and JavaScript the building
blocks of the web along with chat gbt an
AI model developed by open Ai and you'll
even get to work with a tool powered by
Google called Firebase to add a database
to projects but we won't Deep dive into
the technicalities of these languages
and tools or cover the basic concepts
this course is your shortcut to
prototyping and building cool projects
with ai's assistance without worrying
about all the tedious foundational stuff
the focus is helping turn you from a
encoder into a capable Problem Solver Ai
and tools like chat gbt aren't just here
to provide coding answers they can be a
part of your creative process helping
you brainstorm ideas reinforce your
newly learned skills and even enhance
existing code by the of this course
you'll have a collection of fun
interactive and database powered mini
projects that you've built with the help
of chat gbt let's have a look at all the
cool stuff you'll build in the first
section of the course you'll start to
unlock the potential of AI by building
and deploying your first projects using
chubbt you'll start by building what's
called a hero section for a fictitious
product it's an essential part of any
website or landing page then you'll
create a subscription form for a service
called Barker box after that you'll take
things up a notch by building an
interactive invitation that allows
guests to RSVP to an event then you'll
build a fun raffle app where users enter
their names into a cake raffle then it
picks a random winner and you'll turn up
the volume on your building skills
literally by creating an interactive
drum kit app that plays real drum sounds
in section two you'll build Next Level
projects from your own version of the
classic wacka game to an interactive
project slideshow and a personal
homepage to Showcase all your projects
you'll even get to build a mobile
friendly smart home interface and a
Chrome browser extension that saves and
stores shopping wish list items and
section three is a big one it's all
about building database powered apps
with Firebase first you'll connect the
event invite project from section one to
a Firebase database then you'll work on
a compliment generator app to spread
Delight as well as an app called lunch
vote to help you and colleagues decide
on lunch spots and an app called Road
wallet to manage group expenses while
traveling by the end you'll have gained
the confidence to keep building and
turning your ideas into more functional
prototypes and full-fledged applications
regardless of your coding knowledge plus
you'll learn how to deploy your projects
with a service called netlify and share
your awesome work and even transform
projects into Mobile friendly apps that
users can install on their devices and
conveniently launch from their home
screen and your teacher for this course
is me gil Hernandez I'm a teacher at
scrimba and I can't wait to start this
journey and help you unlock your inner
Builder before we start I encourage you
to head over to Discord and let the
scrimba community know that you're
starting the course in the today I will
Channel you can click on this image to
jump right into the Channel all right so
join me in the next lesson where you'll
begin coding and building in a whole new
light with AI and chat gbt see you
there imagine waking up tomorrow as a
web developer what would you want to
build it turns out that with AI tools
like chat gbt you're already a developer
regardless of your experience if you
know how to work with them welcome to a
different kind of coding course that's
less about the intricacies of coding and
more about creating experimenting and
realizing your ideas even without coding
knowhow and this course will use HTML
CSS and JavaScript the building blocks
of the web along with chat GPT an AI
model developed by open AI but we won't
Deep dive into the technicalities of
these languages or cover every basic
concept instead we'll focus on helping
you prototype and build projects with
ai's assistance turning you from a
non-coders into a capable Problem Solver
Ai and tools like chat GPT aren't just
here to provide coding answers they can
be a part of your creative process
helping you brainstorm ideas and
reinforce your newly learned skills by
the end of this course you'll have a
collection of many projects you've built
with the help of chat gbt and more
importantly you'll have gained the
confidence to keep creating and turning
your ideas into actual functional
prototypes regardless of your coding
knowledge plus you'll learn how to
deploy your projects with a service
called net Y and share your awesome work
your teacher for this course is me gil
Hernandez I'm a teacher at scrimba and I
can't wait to start this journey and
help you unlock your inner Builder
before we begin I encourage you to head
over to Discord and let the scrimba
community know that you're starting the
course in the today I will Channel click
on this image here to jump right into
the Channel all right so join me in the
next lesson where you will begin coding
and building in a whole new light with
AI and chat TBT I'll see you
there
let's explore how AI specifically chat
GPT can help you yes even non-coders to
build amazing products you see in recent
years artificial intelligence has
transformed from science fiction to a
real world tool that people from all
walks of life can use but AI isn't just
about robots and self-driving cars it's
about augmenting our capabilities and
making tasks easier which opens up a
world of possibilities chubbt is what's
called a a generative AI program which
means that it can create new and
original content based on the data it's
been trained on as a result chat GPT can
assist with everything from writing
jokes recipes songs and poems and serve
as your intelligent coding assistant now
let's get more specific how exactly can
an AI tool like chat gbt help us with
coding projects well here's the thing
coding at its core is about problem
solving and chat TBT is designed to be a
stellar problem solver for instance it
can help you break down large
intimidating projects into manageable
tasks you simply describe your project
to chat GPT and it can generate basic
steps for getting started and even lay
out a road map for you to follow then it
can suggest potential Solutions and
provide code Snippets that you can use
directly or modify to suit your needs
now if you're a non- coder this might
seem like a daunting Prospect but don't
worry chat GPT can guide you through the
basics of HTML CSS and JavaScript using
simple and understandable language and
remember if you need help understanding
something chat GPT is right there to
help explain tricky Concepts or offer
hints and AI or chat PT in particular is
not here to replace developers rather
it's here to empower Builders like you
and augment your creativity and problem
solving abilities so I hope that you're
excited about the potential of AI and
chat GPT in building your projects let's
keep it going by accessing and using
chat GPT to explore some
code if you're already set up with chat
TBT feel free to skip this if not let me
take a moment to walk you through
signing up and accessing chat gbt chat
gbt was developed by the open AI
research lab so to use chat GPT you'll
need to create an open AI account on
open.com it's free and quick to do you
can click right on this image to go to
the site once you're on the open AI
website click the sign up button and
enter your email and a a desired
password to begin setting up your
account you'll then need to quickly
verify your email address name and phone
number for security reasons after that
you should be all signed up and set up
with an open AI account to access chat
GPT click on your user Avatar in the top
right corner and select visit chat GPT
from the drop down menu or click right
on this image to visit chat.
open.com once there you can see some
onscreen instructions and examples of
how to interact with chat upbt and learn
more about its capabilities and
limitations after you've accessed chat
GPT I want you to explore it type a
sentence or a question in the chat
interface and see how chat GPT responds
you'll be surprised at how
conversational and informative the AI
model can be now while we are going to
be using it for coding assistance chat
GPT is not exclusively designed for
coding it's a general purpose language
model that's been trained on a large
variety of content from the internet
including many examples of code although
it doesn't understand code in the same
way a human developer does it can
generate code based on the patterns and
structures it has learned during its
training all right now that you're all
set up with chat TBT we'll take a
highlevel tour of the basics of HTML and
CSS and get you ready to start
building let's spend some time talking
about the first two essential tools
you'll need in your Web building toolbox
HTML and CSS HTML or hypertext markup
language and CSS which is short for
cascading stylesheets are like the bread
and butter of web development they both
work together to help create the
websites and apps we visit every day and
understanding the basics of both will
help you get the most out of this course
one of my favorite analogies for these
that we use at scrimba is to imagine
building a car think of HTML as the
blueprint for a car laying out all the
key structural components like the frame
steering wheel seats tires and so on it
defines the car's essential parts and
how they fit together to make the car we
still want the car to look good and be
comfortable so that's where CSS comes in
think of CSS as like the exterior design
and interior Furnishings of the car like
the paint job the style and comfort of
the seats the layout of the dashboard
and any of the presentational or styling
aspects that make the car not just
functional but visually appealing and
Driver friendly too in a web development
context HTML gives structure to our web
content determining where paragraphs
headings images and links go and CSS
adds the style choosing colors fonts and
layout options together HTML and CSS
help create a well structured and
aesthetically pleasing site or app so
now let's see how chat GPT can help us
in this process first let's ask it to
generate the a basic HTML structure for
a web page to do that I've written a
prompt here for the AI in the file
prompts MD as you'll learn prompts are
essentially the instructions we feed
into the AI and it's our way of
communicating what we want the AI to do
in this case I want it to generate the
basic HTML structure for a web page so
I'll copy this prompt and paste it into
chat gbt's message input field submit it
and chat GPT returns HTML code that you
can copy and paste into your text editor
you include your Project's HTML code in
a file with the HTML extension like
index.html so I'll click copy code to
copy all of this HTML code and replace
everything that's currently in
index.html with this new code so these
are some of the basic HTML tags which
are used to define the structure and
elements of a web page an opening tag
like this marks the beginning of an
element and the closing cling tag marks
the end now don't worry about what these
meta tags it gave us mean right now
they're just there to help with
character encoding and how the web page
gets displayed and this body element is
where we place the main content of the
web page such as text images links
paragraphs and other elements in this
case we have an H1 heading and a
paragraph So any content placed inside
this body element is what we see in the
web browser here in the scrim you can
click the Run button to view the web
page in the mini browser so cool there
we see welcome to my web page and then
some content below it all right now
let's make this HTML and Page look good
we'll use this second promp here to ask
jbt to add some basic CSS to this page
so I'll copy this promp and feed it into
chat gbt and now I get back the HTML
with a style block added that includes
the CSS styles for the web page so I'll
copy this new HTML code and replace B
everything inside
index.html with this code and good
notice how the CSS sort of transforms
our barebones HTML page into something
more visually engaging and there are a
few ways to apply CSS styles to your
HTML you can include the CSS Styles
directly within your HTML file like this
however this can make your HTML
excessively large and messy so it's
better to include the HTML and CSS in
separate files that's what you'll do in
most of your projects so what I'll do is
ask the AI to place the HTML and CSS in
separate files using this prompt which
I'll paste into chat
GPT and there we go we get the code for
index.html and styles.css so first I'll
once again copy this HTML code and
replace everything that's in index.html
with this new code and you include your
CSS Styles in a file with a CSS
extension like styles . CSS so I'll copy
the new code for styles.css then replace
what's currently in styles.css with this
new code and as you can see the page
still looks the same the difference is
that now the HTML and CSS are placed in
separate files and that's being done
here via the link tag which is what
connects the HTML file to the CSS file
it's a whole lot easier to manage and
organize your HTML and CSS this way all
right so if you have a look at the CSS
you'll see what are called selectors
that Target or select specific HTML
elements and apply styles to them for
example this selects the body element
this here selects the H1 element using
the H1 tag and then the P tag or
paragraph element is selected here okay
so now it's your turn I want you to play
around with the HTML and CSS code here
in this scrim change the text or add
more text in the HTML for example
welcome to Gill's web page or alter the
colors in the CSS for example I can make
this heading Red by simply typing red
here as the color value and we see this
main heading change to red or try
changing any of the other CSS properties
to see how they affect the page and if
the cart analogy from earlier didn't
really make things stick for you or you
want to make HTML and CSS more relatable
to you think of a scenario or a hobby
you enjoy for instance if you like to
cook imagine how an analogy relating to
cooking would help you understand HTML
and CSS better using a prompt like this
I'm interested in learning HTML and CSS
with an analogy related to cooking I'll
submit that to chat GPT and the output
suggests thinking of HTML as the list of
ingredients in the step-by-step
instructions in a recipe and that CSS is
like the seasoning and presentation of a
dish and then it expands upon this
analogy to paint a more Vivid picture
and one of the objectives of this course
is for you to be able to ask the AI for
explanations on specific parts of the
code you don't understand so throughout
this course I want you to ask chat GPT
questions or to provide you with more
details about any of the code or
concepts you're curious about or don't
quite understand yet you'll find that as
you progress you'll start understanding
how different HTML tags and CSS Styles
come together to form a web page and how
they fit in with JavaScript which is
another essential building block of web
development and chat gbt will be there
every step of the way assisting you and
guiding you in building your projects so
congrats you've just written your first
lines of HTML and CSS code and now I'll
leave you with a challenge to have you
spend some time tinkering with HTML and
CSS I'll paste the challenge here as a
comment in
index.html first I'd like you to add a
second level heading to the page using
an H2 element and then add a paragraph
below the new heading and I'd also like
you to increase the text size of both
headings I've also included a stretch
goal which is to display a picture on
the page this could be a photo of you or
any image you'd like you can add an
image to the scrim by simply dragging
your image right into the Explorer
sidebar here and don't hesitate to ask
chat GPT for help or ask it any
questions about HTML and CF s I'll see
you in the next Grim where you will
build your first
project all right you've gotten an
overview of HTML and CSS so how can we
start using AI tools to simplify the
process of building projects with HTML
and CSS well you're about to find out so
let's get our feet wet and start by
creating one of the most commonly used
elements on any website or app a login
button more specifically a login with
Twitter button which you've likely seen
before we'll Leverage The Power of our
AI companion chat GPT to guide us
through this process you will work with
HTML to structure the button and then
CSS to make the button look visually
appealing and interactive so that it
looks like this so let's Jump Right In
and ask chat gbt to help us out to kick
things off I have provided two files
index.html and styles.css which you
started to learn about in the previous
lesson and in the file prompts MD I've
added the first prompt I'll use to build
build this login button so in this
prompt I'm assigning the AI a role I'm
saying you are Developer GPT an
assistant that helps write code for
people who don't have coding experience
and then I'm describing the task which
is to create the HTML and CSS files for
a rounded button resembling the Twitter
login button and I requested making the
code easy to understand for non-coders
and to avoid using any complex CSS
layout features I also mentioned more
specific requir requirements like using
basic CSS properties to horizontally
Center the button and to add some space
above it for visual separation and
finally I want chat GPT to document each
CSS property with a short code comment
overall this prompt provides clear
instructions for the task at hand which
is something you should keep in mind
when prompting an AI like chat GPT so
what I'll do is copy this prompt then
head over to chat GPT and paste it into
the message input field send it then
kick back and await the requested code
so here's the generated HTML and CSS and
below it chat GPT provides an
explanation of the code so feel free to
pause for a bit and read through these
details if you'd like to know more about
the HTML and CSS in the HTML file you'll
see common HTML elements like a div and
a button and these class attributes as
you'll see are for the CSS styling and
inside the button there is some text
that says login with Twitter so I'll
copy Cy this HTML code snippet from chat
gbt then replace all the code in
index.html with the new code click the
Run button and good now you should be
able to view the button in the mini
browser displaying the text login with
Twitter all right next I'll copy the CSS
snippet from chat gbt and paste it into
styles.css so this CSS targets or
selects the container and rounded button
class names defined in our HTML then
using CSS properties like text align
background color color and Border it
gives the button a distinctive look
which does in fact resemble the Twitter
login button awesome and chbt was even
intelligent enough to determine which
color to apply to the button to make it
match the Twitter brand and notice that
next to each CSS property is a comment
generated by chat gbt to help us better
understand what the CSS is doing and if
you pause for a moment and review this
code you might be surprised by how much
you might be able to understand many CSS
properties are intuitively named almost
like they're written in plain English so
take for example background color it
does precisely what it says it sets the
background color similarly the color
property defines the text colors and
other properties such as border padding
and font size follow a similar pattern
and together these properties Define the
look and feel of our button and if if
you start to Tinker with some of these
properties you'll learn a bit more about
what they do and how they affect the
appearance of the button for instance if
you change this first padding value to
0er pixels or 50 pixels you might
realize that this property controls the
spacing inside the button or that the
margin top property controls the space
outside and above the button and a
property like font size sets the size of
the text and so on Okay so we've created
our button but but we won't stop here
because now I have a challenge for you I
want you to experiment more with the
HTML and CSS and transform this button
into a login with GitHub Button as a
developer you will likely interact with
a button like this quite a bit you might
immediately notice some of the
differences between this button and the
Twitter login button for example the
GitHub button has a different background
color the borders are not rounded and
the button text is also different so
I'll add the steps to this challenge
here at the top of styles.css this
challenge will require you to modify two
lines of code in the CSS file and one
line of code in the HTML file and I've
also included the color code for the
background of the GitHub button which is
this value here so think about the
changes you need to make and go for it
and remember if you get stuck or need
guidance chat GPT is here to help I'll
meet you back soon to go over the
challenge
together all right hopefully you've
updated your button to look like this
now let's go over the challenge together
first I need to turn the button into a
login with GitHub button which tells me
that I need to update the text between
the button tags here in the HTML file so
I'll replace Twitter with GitHub and
there we go the button now displays
login with GitHub good next I need to
update the CSS to make the button look
more like this and notice how this color
code that starts with a hash symbol
looks a bit like two of the values being
used here in the CSS for the rounded
button so I'll copy this color code and
let's see what happens if I update the
value of the color property to the new
color value well it looks like this just
updates the text color but I want the
text to remain white so I'll undo that
and just above I see that this line here
controls the background color so I'll
replace this color value with the new
color and yep that looks exactly like
what I'm going for finally the login
with GitHub button has square corners
instead of rounded Corners so let's see
how to update that in styles.css looking
at the comments I see that this border
radius property rounds the corners of
the button now currently it's set to 20
PX or pixels so I'm assuming that
setting this to a smaller value will
make the corners appear less rounded so
I'll try 10 pixels and that's looking
closer to square corners so how about
bringing the value down to0 pixels and
yes that does the trick all right so now
we have a simple yet functional and
styled login button that you can start
to use in your projects finally when you
hover over a button or click on it it's
common for the button to be interactive
and respond in some way currently it's
not doing that so let's ask chat GPT to
suggest CSS to add hover and click
effects to update the button's
appearance when it's hovered or clicked
for that I'll use this prompt here it
instructs it to generate the necessary
CSS for adding hover and click effects
on the button and I need to let chat GPT
know that the button now has a
background color set to this value and I
want to make its background color
brighter when hovered over or clicked
and to add a comment next to each CSS
property so I'll copy this prompt paste
it into chat GPT and good I get back the
CSS code for the hover and click effects
which you'll notice that they will be
implemented using colon hover for when
the mouse is over the button and colon
active for when the button is being
clicked so I'll just copy the new CSS
toward the bottom then paste it into
styles.css
and let's test it in the mini browser
when I hover over the button I see that
the background color changes to a
grayish color color and clicking on it
makes it darker great this not only
makes the button more engaging but it
also improves the user experience by
providing visual feedback all right so
that about wraps up building our login
with Twitter and GitHub buttons and
remember while chat GPT does provide an
excellent starting point I do want you
to keep tweaking and modifying this code
to view how each property or value you
change affects the look of the button
and I'm sure that you still might have a
lot of questions about what some of this
code is doing and that's perfectly okay
so what I want you to do is take a
moment to ask chat GPT about any code
that appears confusing or that you want
to learn more about for example what's
the purpose of the hash symbol and color
values or what does colon hover and
active mean to help you ask these
questions I'll provide a prompt here
that asks chat GPT hey can you explain
what the hash symbol and colon hover and
an active mean in the following CSS code
followed by the CSS code snippet to
evaluate so great job building your very
first project with AI I'll see you in
the next Grim where we'll go over some
of the basics of
prompting all right AI coders let's see
some of these prompting techniques in
action now we're going to design and
build an essential part of any website
or landing page the hero section this is
the first thing your visitors might see
so making a good impression is important
with the help of our AI tool chat upbt
we'll create a vibrant hero section
using HTML and CSS so let's Dive Right
In I've already included HTML and CSS
files for the project as well as an
image we'll use in our page named chair.
PNG first we're going to generate the
HTML and CSS of the hero section so
let's turn to chat gbt for some
assistance in the file prompts MD I've
set up the first prompt to work with
with it's an instruction-based prompt
with specific steps to help us reach the
desired outcome it clearly explains the
desired output which is the HTML and CSS
for a hoverchair website's hero section
and then it provides some context about
the product and it describes exactly
what it should contain a main heading
subheading short description paragraph
and a call to action link styled as a
button it also outlines some guidelines
for the code like making the code easy
to understand stand for non-coders and
avoiding the use of complex CSS features
and it even provides some aesthetic
guidelines like to use an elegant and
neutral color palette with a focus on
earthy tones and subdued Hues and as
usual I want it to document the CSS with
code comments and as a reminder of the
overall goal and purpose of the task it
states that the final result should be
an engaging and Visually appealing hero
section that effectively showcases the
hoverchair brand so I'll just copy and
paste this prompt into chat
GPT and it generates the HTML and CSS
code to set up the hero section so first
I'll copy the HTML code and paste it
into
index.html looking at the HTML structure
I see that it consists of a header
element and nested inside it is a hero
heading subheading and description just
like we asked for and an acre element or
link that's going to be styled to look
like a button with this class name and
here in the mini browser we see the hero
section taking shape so next let's apply
some styles to the page using the CSS
chat GPT gave us I'll click to copy this
code then paste it into styles.css and
wonderful the hero section is starting
to look much better with the CSS applied
so now how about a challenge I'll paste
the steps for you here in styles. CSS so
for this challenge I'd like you to
increase the size of the learn more
button text because it's looking a bit
too small and we do want to draw more
attention to it so users can click on it
and hopefully purchase the amazing hover
chair then I want you to add a little
more color to the Page by changing the
text color of the subheading which is
this element here to the color value
provided here so give it a shot and I'll
catch up with you when you're done to go
over it
together okay hopefully you got that so
first to increase the size of the button
text I see that the button is this
element here with the class name ca-
button so in the CSS I'll find that
class name which is this CSS rule here
and you've learned that the font size
property is what controls the size of
text so to make the font size larger
I'll set it to to a value such as 24
pixels and that looks much better to me
you can see the difference here when I
set it back to 18 pixels then 24 pixels
or maybe make it larger such as 26
pixels all right next I'll change the
color of the subheading to this value
here so I'll copy it and in the HTML I
see that the subheading has the class
hero- subheading so I'll scroll down and
find that class name right here and I
see that the color property is set to
this color value so I'll update it with
the new color and see what that looks
like and awesome that did it I really
like how the page is looking so if you
got this well done now another detail I
might add is to increase the line height
or the space between the lines of text
here in the hero description for that
I'll use the CSS line height property
here in the hero description Rule and
I'll open up the line height a bit more
by setting it to a value like
1.4 and to me that looks much better and
easier to read all right now let's add
another important element to our hero
section an image in our project files we
have an image named chair. PNG that I
want to place above the hero heading
naturally we'll ask chat GPT to do that
but this time I'll use a more direct
prompt by asking the AI to update the
HTML and CSS by adding a small rounded
image named chair. PNG above the hero
heading and to add some depth and
highlight the image I also want to apply
a soft Shadow behind the image so I'll
paste this into chat
GPT and good here's the updated HTML
with an image tag that points to the
image in our project named chair. PNG
and displays it on the page I'll test
how it looks by adding only the new
image tag to my HTML just above the hero
heading like this and okay that's
working but the image is huge so now
let's make it smaller and rounded by
applying the CSS the image element has
the class name Logo so here in the css.
logo selects and applies styles to that
element so I'll just copy the new styles
that get applied to the image and paste
it in my CSS let's have a look at it now
and excellent the product image makes a
big big difference in our hero section
and now the image has that nice rounded
effect thanks to the CSS border radius
property and the shadow gives the image
a sense of depth and separation from the
background so looking at the new CSS you
might be wondering what this box Shadow
property and rgba value are all about
well as the comet describes it adds the
soft Shadow to the image but I don't
want you to just take my word for it if
you want a deeper explanation take full
full advantage of chat GPT and ask it to
provide that for you along with anything
else you might have questions about now
the image is looking rather small so I
think it might be best to make it larger
I'll let you do that with a challenge so
pause the scrim and use CSS to increase
the size of the image the size you
choose is up to
you all right here we go hopefully you
figured out that the width property is
is what controls the size of the image
so let's see I'll increase the width
value here to something like 300 pixels
and I think that's too big so I'll
reduce it to 180 pixels and that looks
better to me if you made it a different
size that's perfectly fine finally I
want this hero heading to stand out now
one thing I can do is increase the text
size using a larger font size value like
58 pixels and that looks better but I
also want it to have a different font
than the rest of the content on the page
so Google offers a library of free web
fonts called Google fonts that can be
easily accessed and used in your
projects you can see an example of it
here and rubric is a Google font that I
particularly like so I'm going to ask
chat GPT to add the rubric font to my
project and update the heading text I'll
use a prompt that says please use HTML
and CSS to set the hero headings font to
the rubic Google font so I'll feed this
prompt to chat
gbt and it gives me back a link tag to
include the rubic Google font in my
project so I'll copy just this link tag
in the new HTML and paste it in the head
section of my
HTML and I see that the new CSS has a
font family property that sets the
headings font to Rubik so I'll copy that
and then paste it in the hero heading
Rule and here you can see that the hero
heading does in fact have a different
font than the rest of the content now
it's a very subtle difference but a nice
Added Touch to the page all right and
there you have it our website hero is
complete so great work next we'll move
on to our next project but before that I
want you to play around with the hero
section change the content colors fonts
the buttons style make it your own and
you can also replace the chair. PNG
image with your own image by dragging
the image into the Explorer sidebar then
updating this Source attribute in the
image tag to your image name I'll see
you soon in the next
lesson all right let's build something
that you'll likely find useful a
subscription form you've probably seen
these on various websites and now we're
going to build one for a subscription
service called Barker box which you'll
also be able to customize to your liking
so let's get into it I have included the
usual HTML and CSS files for this
project as well as the image we'll use
which is named dog. jpeg like in
previous projects I want the AI to do a
lot of the heavy lifting for me and
generate most of the HTML and CSS I need
to build this form so I'll kick things
off using this task-based instructional
prompt this prompt provides a specific
set of instructions for for creating
HTML and CSS files for a form offering a
15% discount to new subscribers of a
product or service called Barker box
which is a monthly subscription box that
brings an assortment of unique playful
and durable toys that dogs will love the
prompt also outlines the steps to be
followed including creating a headline
adding a product description and
building a registration form with an
email input put and a submit button and
it specifies the color and background
properties to use and it also emphasizes
making the code beginner friendly and to
include code comments for better
understanding so I'll copy and paste
this prompt into chat gbt and I get back
the HTML and CSS code so I'll copy the
HTML code snippet and paste it into
index.html and copy and paste the CSS
into styles.css
so in this code there might be some HTML
elements and CSS properties you haven't
seen before so let's spend a little time
going through this code together first
the HTML includes a form element to
create the subscription form and inside
the form are two common elements used
with forms an input field and a button
notice how the input field is of type
email which means that the user is
required to enter an email address
address in the correct format it has an
ID of email and the placeholder text
enter your email and that's the text
that gets displayed in the input field
here when it's empty which gives the
user an idea of what to type into it and
this required attribute indicates that
the user must provide an input before
they can submit the form and the button
element which you've worked with before
is of type submit which means that when
clicked it will submit the form data but
this form won't be programmed to submit
any data as that requires more
programming and over in the CSS a lot of
these properties should look familiar
well all except for maybe display flex
and flex Direction column so it looks
like chat GPT generated CSS that uses a
feature called flexbox to lay out the
registration form flexbox gives you a
more efficient way to layout align and
distribute space among items in your
layout and this this case the form
elements are neatly aligned and laid out
in a column in fact if you comment out
or delete the CSS you can see what
flexbox is doing without it they both
shift onto the same row but with display
flex and flex Direction column the text
field and button appear neatly stacked
on top of each other and this is really
going to help us soon when adding a
second input field now if anything still
feels unclear don't hesitate to ask chat
GPT questions or ask for a simpler
explanation of HTML forms and CSS
flexbox okay now that you're up to speed
let's get into customizing this page
first is just a simple content change
that I want to make here in the heading
I want to update the text to say
subscribe and save 15% just to make the
headline more descriptive and chat TBT
generated CSS to make the form container
adjust and resize according to the
browser width which is great but it
looks like the page needs some padding
to create a little more visual
separation between the edges of the
container and the
browser so I'll apply some left and
right padding here in the body rule I'll
replace this padding zero declaration
with padding left and let's say 20
pixels and below that padding right 20
pixels that looks much better now we can
clearly see the left and right edges of
the form container even on narrow screen
sizes and devices all right so I think
that this description paragraph would
look a little better and cleaner if it
was left align with the form elements
and I want to add another text field to
the form that lets users type their name
so how about you do that with a
challenge in this challenge you will
left align the text in the description
paragraph and then in the form create a
required name input field and here's a
hint its type should be set to the value
text so pause me now give that a go and
I'll see you in a bit to go over this
together all right hopefully that went
well let's give it a go so first I will
left align the text in the description
paragraph that's being done here now
currently I see that text align is set
to the Value Center so let's see what
happens if I change this from text align
Center to text align left and yep that
does what I want it to but it turns out
that the value left is the default text
align Direction so we can actually
delete this line Al together and it
works just like we want it to okay next
is the name input field to do that I can
just copy the code for the email input
I'll copy it and paste a new input above
it and in the challenge I mentioned that
its type should be text currently it's
email so I'll change this to text and
the value email is specific typically
used for email input fields to check
that an email address is in the correct
format but when you have an input field
where users need to enter text such as
their name you set its type to text I'll
follow a similar pattern here by setting
the ID to name and the placeholder text
to enter your name and this is also
going to be a required field and that's
being set up here with the required
attributes all right let's have a look
I'll bring up my form click refresh and
good the new input field appears stacked
on top of the email field and that's
again all being done with flexbox and if
you click the submit button without
entering your name since the field is
set to be required you should also see a
message that lets you know to fill out
the field so hey if you got the steps
for this challenge well done let's move
on to the next challenge which I'll
paste in here and this time I want you
to display the dog. jpeg image image
above the H1 element and to give the
image the class featured image and when
you display the image on the page you'll
notice that it'll need some adjustments
and that's okay we'll take that on after
with CSS only worry about these two
steps right now so go for it and I'll
meet you back
soon all right hopefully you were able
to display the dog image you've worked
with images in previous projects so
let's take a moment to go over that here
just above the H1 element I'll add the
image using the image tag and to apply
the class featured image I'll add a
class attribute and between quotes write
feature Das image let's not forget the
closing bracket then to display the
image on the page I need to add the
source attribute and point to my image
which is named dog. JPEG and one
important attribute when working with
embedded images is the alt attribute and
what that does is is provide alternative
text for an image for instance if the
image source is broken the image can't
be loaded or the user is using a screen
reader the text you type in here is
going to be displayed or read to the
user the image itself is an illustration
of a happy dog so for the alt text I'll
write illustration of a happy dog if you
figured out that you needed to include
an ALT attribute fantastic as it's an
important attribute when working with
image elements now as I mentioned
earlier the image appears way too large
and out of place so now I want you to
write CSS to adjust the size and shape
of the image I'll add the steps for
another challenge here in styles.css so
this time I want you to style the image
by selecting the class featured image
and then making the image smaller so
that it's about 100 pixels wide and I
want you to apply rounded Corners to the
image so think about what you need to do
give it a go and I'll catch you in AIT
bit to go over this challenge
together all right hopefully that wasn't
too bad and you were able to get through
all or most of these steps now let's go
over it together first I'll select the
class featured image which is done using
a period like this container selector
here so I'll type dot featured image and
then open up a set of curly brackets
then to make the image smaller I'll use
the width property and set it to 100
pixels
and I see that worked and to apply
rounded Corners I can use the Border
radius property like we're doing here so
how about I just copy this line of code
here and paste it in my featured image
rule and that looks pretty good but I
want the image to be perfectly rounded
and the way you do that is by setting
the Border radius value to
50% and now we get a perfectly rounded
image if you didn't make your image
perfectly rounded that's okay the next
thing I want to do is horizontally
Center align the image above the heading
because it's looking a bit weird left
align and centering would make the
design more balanced so I'll try to do
that here in the featured image rule
let's see earlier we used the text align
property to align the content so what if
I set text align to Center well that
didn't work like it did for the
paragraph So instead how about just
asking chat GPT to give me the code for
that so I'll ask it this prompt here
I'll say hey what's the simplest way to
horizontally Center align this new
featured image and below I provide a
code snippet of the image and H1 so I'll
submit this to chat GPT and it says that
to horizontally Center the image you can
use CSS by setting the display property
of the image to block and applying the
margin property with a value of zero
Auto and I get the updated CSS for that
so I'll just copy these two lines lines
of code that used the display and margin
properties to horizontally Center the
image then paste it into the featured
image rule and it looks like that did
the trick good while we're here I also
want to create more space between the
heading and the image and I can do that
with margins so for example I can add a
margin bottom property and set it to 20
pixels and the spacing here looks much
better but here's a trick this is
actually a margin shorthand property
where the first value sets the top and
bottom margin and the second value sets
the left and right margin so if I set
the first margin value to 20 pixels it
looks and works the same and if I add a
third value that controls the bottom
margin so in this case I want the top
margin to be 10 pixels the left and
right margins to remain Auto to create
that horizontal centering but I'll add a
third value that controls the bottom
margin Marin only and that opens up the
spacing on both the top and bottom sides
of the image all right finally how about
applying a nice border to the rounded
image that matches the color of the main
heading and I want you to try something
using chat GPT go ahead and open a new
chat and feed it this directive prompt
The Prompt for this challenge asks chat
GPT to generate only the CSS needed to
apply a 3 pixel border to this image
using this color value here in this case
chat GPT doesn't really need to know the
context of your project this image code
snippet should be all it needs to give
you the necessary CSS so pause me now
ask chat GPT and then add the new CSS to
the
project all right hopefully you were
able to make that work I'll open up a
new chat window then provide the prompt
to chat GPT and I get back a CSS code
snippet that applies a 3 pixel solid
border to the image with the provid
added color so I'll copy this line of
code then paste it inside the featured
image rule let's have a look the border
is a nice Added Touch and it makes the
image stand out a little bit more on the
page all right so that about wraps up
the subscription form project and I want
you to take some time before you move on
to ask chat GPT to explain anything that
seems confusing or that you want to
learn more about you've made lots of
progress building with AI and HTML and
CSS and up next we'll take a big step
toward adding more power and
interactivity to our projects with
JavaScript you've learned a bit about
HTML and CSS and used it to build some
projects now it's time to learn another
essential building block in web
development JavaScript in this Grim
you'll get an overview of what
JavaScript is why it's important and how
it fits into the larger picture of web
development together with HTML and CSS
think back to the HTML and CSS car
analogy if HTML is like the structural
building blocks of the car and CSS is
the car's style look and feel then think
of JavaScript as the part that powers
the car's functionality like the car's
engine and smart features without
JavaScript our car might be
aesthetically pleasing but it won't do
much with JavaScript we breathe life and
interactivity to the otherwise static
structure and design for example the
doors unlock when we approach the car
the ignition starts with a button and
the car moves when we push the
accelerator all interactive all thanks
to JavaScript in web development
JavaScript is responsible for making
websites and apps functional and
interactive it enables us to respond to
user actions like clicks or key presses
manipulate content on the page and even
communicate with servers to process
store and retrieve data now you might be
wondering how can I as a non-coders
start using JavaScript well that's where
our handy AI assistant comes in just
like we did with HTML and CSS we can ask
chat GPT to generate JavaScript code for
us and help explain what it's doing
let's say we want to implement a simple
interaction we'd like a welcome message
to appear when we click a button so
let's ask chat GPT to create this
JavaScript code for us I'll use this
prompt which asks can you generate a
basic HTML and JavaScript example where
clicking a button logs a welcome message
please add comments to help me
understand the code I'll copy this
prompt and paste it into chat
and it Returns the HTML code which I'll
copy and paste into
index.html the HTML contains a button
element with an ID of my button and in
this case the pages JavaScript is placed
directly in the HTML file within script
tags the JavaScript gets a reference to
the button element with the ID my button
and assigns it to a variable named
button using this special VAR keyword
you can think of a variable as like like
a container used to store information
assigning the button element to this
button variable makes it easier to work
with a button and make things happen
when it's clicked for example the code
here pays close attention to our button
using what's called an event listener so
that anytime it's clicked something
happens in our page or some
functionality that we Define between
these curly braces gets executed in this
case it's logging the welcome message
written here between quotes to the
browser console and the browser console
is a tool that's built into web browsers
that allows you to run and test
JavaScript code and display messages and
console.log is what's used to display or
log messages in the console in fact this
scrim editor also has a built-in console
that's this area here so I'll click the
Run button to run this code and when I
click the button in the mini browser the
welcome message appears inside it good
so now I have a quick challenge for you
I'll includeed it here as a comment
between the script tags and what I want
you to do is display your name in this
welcome message so it might say
something like welcome Gil for example
so pause me now and give that a
try all right to display my name in The
Welcome message I'll update the text
that's passed into
console.log the message is written
inside quotes and any value or data you
see in JavaScript written within single
or double quotes is called a string So
within the quotes I'll simply add
welcome Gil I'll run the latest code
click the button and I get the new
message displaying my name so next how
about we display this welcome message on
the page instead of in the
console so using this prompt I'll ask
chat GPT to please update the code so
that clicking the button displays a
welcome message on the page so I'll
paste this prompt into chat GPT and we
get back the updated code and including
an overview of the changes which you can
read through I'll copy the new code
snippet and replace everything in
index.html with it and looking at the
HTML I see that it now includes a div
with an ID of message container to
display our message and like it did with
the button the JavaScript references the
new message container div and assigns it
to a variable named message container
and this line uses the message container
variable to update the text content of
the container and display the welcome
message so I'll click run to run my
latest JavaScript and when I click the
button I should see the message appear
on the page and there it is good similar
to how we've written HTML and CSS in
separate files it's common to place your
JavaScript in a separate file that uses
the JS extension like script.js so let's
do that I'll ask chat GPT to place the
HTML in JavaScript in separate files
files and to style the page with CSS so
I'll feed this prompt into chat gbt and
let it do its thing and I get back the
code for HTML JavaScript and CSS files
so I'll replace my HTML with this new
HTML code snippet then copy the
JavaScript code and paste it into my
script.js file and if you're curious you
link a Javascript file to your HTML
using the script tag like so in this
case it's pointing to script.js
next I'll copy the CSS code into
styles.css
run all my latest code and that
horizontally centures the button and
makes it slightly larger I'll click the
button and the welcome message appears
all right so I have one more JavaScript
challenge for you I want you to use a
JavaScript variable to dynamically
display your name in The Welcome message
so your challenge is to create a
variable named first name and a sign it
your name and I'm going to update this
line here so that it uses the first name
variable you define to display your name
in the message all right so take it away
the scrim is all
yours all right now let's go over the
challenge together to create a variable
named first name I'll use the VAR
keyword followed by first name then type
an equal sign to assign it my name
between quotes or as a string and if you
don't place this inside quotes the
JavaScript interpreter will produce an
error so as you can see here the red
squiggly line lets you know that
something is not quite right and in
JavaScript semicolons are optionally
used to Mark the end of a statement so I
can type one here to be consistent with
the rest of the code all right so now
whatever I assigned to the first name
variable should appear here so let's try
it out I'll click the button and good
the message says welcome Gil so if you
did something similar nice work
especially if this was your first time
working with variables in JavaScript
another way you might see variables
written in JavaScript is using the
keyword let which is easier to
understand because if you read this out
loud you might realize that we're just
telling JavaScript to let first name
equal or B Gill and you will see
variables used a lot in JavaScript
programming okay we've covered a lot in
this lesson and if you still don't quite
understand some things about this
JavaScript code don't worry but but I
really do want you to take full
advantage of asking chat GPT to help you
understand certain Concepts especially
while building projects as you work more
with these tools and continue to build
your projects you'll start to recognize
patterns and understand more about how
HTML CSS and JavaScript work to help you
out in the meantime I'll provide a
prompt you can use to get a refresher or
learn more about the basics of what we
covered in this lesson so you can say to
chat GPT hey I'm new to JavaScript
please help me understand the basics of
these Concepts and like in an earlier
lesson when we covered the basics of
HTML and CSS you can ask chat GPT to
relate HTML CSS and JavaScript and how
they work together to your own interests
or Hobbies so here's a suggestion for
how you might prompt chat GPT you can
say I enjoy gardening how can I
understand HTML CSS and JavaScript in
the context of planting and maintaining
a garden so explore some of these
prompts and I'll see you in the next
grim where we'll begin applying
JavaScript to
projects we are going to be throwing an
epic event called GIF Gaya where guests
dress up as their favorite gifts or
memes we'll need to build an interactive
invitation to allow guests to RSVP to
the event we can do that using HTML CSS
and JavaScript With a Little Help from
chat gbt this is a bigger project so
we're going to take it step by step
using a series of role playing and
instructional prompts where we guide the
AI with specific steps to reach the
desired outcome it's going to hopefully
look something like this but first we
need to work on creating the HTML
structure of the event invite which
might look like this I've set up the
project with HTML CSS and JavaScript
files the first step is to ask chat GPT
to generate the HTML structure of our
invitation and I've provided the prompt
will use for that the prompt asks the AI
to assume the role of a highly sought
after designer and provides some context
and objectives for the role to play then
it provides Specific Instructions and
details about what needs to be done
which in this case is creating a vibrant
festive RSVP page below it guides the AI
on what elements the page should have
such as an invitation header with a
title a subheading showing the date an
event description and a space to display
a confirmation message then it instructs
it to create an RS VP form with a
required email field an attendance field
and a submit button and we also wanted
to link the HTML to a CSS and JavaScript
file so I'll just feed this into cat GPT
and it generates the HTML code outlining
the basic structure of our page so I'll
copy and paste this code into
index.html and there might be some HTML
tags here that you may not have seen
before like Main and section these are
known as semantic elements that help
provide meaningful information about the
content the main element describes the
main content of the page and section
defines specific sections in the page
and we also have a select element which
is commonly used in form elements to
create a drop-down list of options in
this case the user can select whether
they are attending or not okay great now
that we've established our structure we
need to apply styling and that's where
CSS comes in next I'll use this prompt
to style the RSVP page it continues with
the assumed role by instructing the AI
to use its CSS skills to style the gift
Gaya invitation so that it's easily
viewable on mobile and desktop and I
want the page to be visually engaging
and fun as possible to match the event's
Lively and playful spirit and the
instruction to initially hide the
confirmation message indicates a
consideration for some JavaScript
interactivity and I want CSS comments to
help non-coders understand the code more
easily so let's see what magic we can
cook up with this prompt I'll copy and
paste this CSS into styles.css and good
our invite is taking shape and already
looking more festive so let's have a
look at the CSS we've got here I see CSS
used to reset some of the default Styles
applied to the browser then a lot of CSS
properties that we've worked with
before and remember how I asked the AI
to initially hide the confirmation
message on the page that's being done
here with display none and soon we'll
make it appear on the page dynamically
using JavaScript when the form is
submitted and then I see something
different here under responsive Styles I
asked the AI to make the page easily
viewable on mobile and desktop so this
at media syntax here is what's called a
media query it lets us apply different
styles to a page based on the width or
size of the browser window or the device
where the content is being viewed in
this case Max with 600 pixels means that
the CSS included Within These curly
braces will get applied to our page only
if the width of the browser is 600
pixels or less so for example if I set
the background color of this main
element to Red notice how the red
background does not appear when the
browser is wide and only appears when I
shrink its width down to 600 pixels or
less
less now here in the media query I see
that the font size for most of the
content is being updated so notice how
some of the text size changes too for
smaller
screens all right now I want you to hack
around and customize the page with a
challenge I asked the AI for a vibrant
and festive color scheme and this color
scheme doesn't quite hit the mark I
think so I want you to explore making
the page more vibrant and festive using
these two color values for example
change the background color of the
header and the button or the color of
the headings and it looks like the
spacing in the form needs some work too
so I also want you to add more space
between the input field select menu and
submit button so pause me now and work
through
these okay now let's go over the
challenge together to make the invite a
little more vibrant I'll update the
background color of the header to this
color value here and the background
color of the submit button to this
second value so I'll scroll down to the
CSS styling the button and replace the
background color property with the new
value and why not I'll also change the
color of these headings here to match
the color of the button those are these
H3 tags here so in the CSS for the H3
I'll add the color property and set it
to that color value all right that is
looking better to me finally there are a
few ways I might update the space
between the input select and submit
button what I'll do is apply a bottom
margin to the input field and the select
menu and I can do that here in this CSS
rule that targets both at once I'll add
margin bottom 18
pixels and that creates the spacing I
need much better if you used a different
approach than me that's completely fine
all right now to add some life to this
party we'll need JavaScript it will make
our page interactive allowing the invite
to respond and behave in specific ways
based on user input so let's ask chat
GPT to add some interaction to our page
I have here another instructional prompt
that gives the AI Specific Instructions
to create JavaScript code to enhance the
interactivity of the RSVP page then I
provide clear tasks about the desired
interaction which is to check if the
user selected attending and then display
a party emoji and a positive message if
they are attending and I'm also being
specific about where the message should
appear in the confirmation message space
and I requested adding brief comments to
the JavaScript logic to make it more
understandable for an encoder so let's
feed this prompt to chat gbt and it
generates the JavaScript I'll need which
I'll copy and paste into
script.js so let's go over this
JavaScript first it gets the form and
confirmation message elements and
assigns them to variables and you may
notice a new keyword const being used
for the variables const is another
common way to declare a variable in
JavaScript unlike the lat and VAR
keywords when you use const you're
creating a variable that cannot be
changed or reassigned once it has been
set so in other words it's a constant
value throughout your program then the
code pays close attention to when a user
submits the form and then runs all of
this code each time it's submitted and
this line here event prevent default is
commonly used with forms to give you
more control over the form submission
and prevent the default browser Behavior
associated with submitting forms then
here we're getting the selected
attendance value and assigning it to the
variable attendance and this code here
displays a confirmation message based on
attendance selection it uses a common
statement in JavaScript called an if
statement that checks if the variable
attendance or what the user selected is
equal to the string yes if it's yes it
sets the HTML content within the
confirmation message div to display a
celebratory message then it shows the
confirmation on the Page by setting its
display to block and it resets or clears
the form here all right let's try it out
I'll enter an email then select that I'm
attending click submit and look at that
we've got some interactivity on our page
below we get the message partyon we look
forward to seeing you at the gift Gaya
good now I think that it would look
better if the confirmation message
appeared above the form so in
index.html I'll move this confirmation
message div above the RSVP form
section I'll test it out and that looks
much better now it does look like I need
to add some space between the
confirmation message and RSVP heading
and I can do that with a bottom margin
so here in the confirmation CSS let's
say a margin bottom 20 pixels that looks
good and then we no longer need to apply
the bottom margin to the form so I'll
just remove this entire form rule from
the CSS great our gift Gaya invite is
looking sharp up next we'll continue
working on more interactivity with
JavaScript it looks like chat gbt gave
us the JavaScript code to display the
confirmation message only if the user is
attending notice how it displays a blank
section if I select that I'm not
attending well this was intentional
because now I want you to work on
displaying a different confirmation
message if a user selects that they are
not attending here's the challenge
update the JavaScript below to display
this message if the user selects the
option sorry I can't make it use this
code here as a reference for what you'll
need to do and don't hesitate to ask
chat GPT for help either so pause me now
get coding and I'll show you my my
solution when you're
done all right if you got it to work
well done there are a few ways you might
have displayed the message to users not
attending I did suggest using this if
statement as a reference so you could
have maybe copied this code block pasted
a new one below and updated it to if
attendance is equal to no then set
confirmation message to this
message and let's see I'll select sorry
I can't make it and this works just like
we needed to if you use this approach in
your Solution that's great but there are
other statements we can use with the if
statement to create a conditional
statement that performs different
actions based on different conditions
one of those is else if so here if the
attendance value is yes then the program
skips checking whether attendance is no
and displays this message now if
attendance is not yes then it checks if
the attendance is equal to no then
displays the proper message and I'll
test it out here and you can see that it
works in the exact same way assuming
attendance can only be yes or no you
could also write this using an if else
statement like so so we can just have
else without attendance is equal to no
and this way if attendance is not yes
then it must be no so this code should
run either of these approaches is fine
and if you'd like to learn more about
JavaScript conditional statements I'll
provide some prompts here that you can
use with chat
GPT now this is the GIF Gala after all
so the last thing we'll work on is
customizing the JavaScript to display a
gif in the background based on what the
user selects for attendance so with this
prompt I'm instructing the AI to update
the JavaScript and CSS to display this
image as the page background if the user
is attending and that the image should
cover the entire background area of the
body so I'll paste this into chat GPT
and let's see what we get all right so
I'll copy this JavaScript code and
replace everything in script.js with
this new JavaScript so it looks like
this code is getting a reference to the
body element and assigning it to the
variable body and this line here sets
the background image of the body element
directly using the style. background
image property and this URL function is
what tells the browser to load the image
file and use it as the background so
when the user is attending or attendance
is equal to Yes it sets the body
elements background to the provided
image URL and if the user is not
attending or attendance is equal to no
then the body's background image style
gets sets To None to remove the
background image and in the CSS code
background size cover ensures that the
image covers the entire background area
of the body and background position
center centers the image within the body
so I'll copy these two properties then
paste them in my body rule here in the
CSS so let's test the latest changes
I'll enter an email select yes I'll be
there click submit and awesome we see
the party gift displaying in the
background now if you make the browser
window taller you'll notice that the
image is repeating itself here toward
the bottom to fix this we can add a
couple of CSS properties here in the
body rule first I don't want the
background image to repeat so I can use
the background repeat property and set
it to the value no repeat to prevent
that then I'll add a height property and
if I set the height value to 100 VH it
means that I want it to take up 100% of
the viewport height which is what VH
means or the total height of the visible
area in the browser so I'll refresh the
mini browser try it out again enter my
email select that I'm attending click
submit and now I shouldn't see the party
gift repeat heating or any empty spaces
below it and I don't fantastic now don't
we also want to display a different
image if the user is not attending yeah
I think that makes sense and I want you
to work on that part for this last
challenge so take a moment to update the
JavaScript to display this GIF if the
user is not attending pause me now and
go for
it all right hopefully you got the not
attending gift to display so if the user
selects not attending that means that
the value of attendance is equal to no
and currently that sets the background
image to nun so I'll copy this URL
function here and replace none with it
and then Within These quotes I'll add
the URL to this
GIF and that should work I'll test it
out enter an email select sorry I can't
make it click submit and yes there is
our sad GIF displaying in the background
now I do want more of the background GIF
to show through so I'll create a
semi-transparent background for that
I'll even ask chat GPT hey which CSS
property creates a white
semi-transparent background and here in
the output I see that the CSS property
that creates a white semi-transparent
background is background color with this
rgba value here this rgba color model
lets you set an alpha value that
determines the level of transparency for
the color so I'll copy this background
color property and I want the main
element to be semi-transparent so I'll
paste it here in the main Rule and
here's the alpha value which is set to
0.5 which in this case means that the
background will be 50% transparent I
want it to be slightly less transparent
so I'll set it to
0.75 which is going to allow some of the
background to show through and that
looks great let's test it with the
attending GIF and and there you have it
you've just built an event invitation
page using HTML CSS and JavaScript all
with help from chbt so nice work
hopefully you picked up new coding
skills along the way let's move on to
our next
project I don't know about you but in
just about every office I've worked in
cake is a big deal birthdays
anniversaries Fridays there's always a
reason for cake but there always seems
to be that one person who ends up
without a piece so we're going to fix
that by building a cake raffle web app
with the help of chat gbt and it might
look something like this the raffle app
will allow users to enter their names
into a cake raffle then it will pick a
random winner with a click of a draw
Button as usual I've set up the project
with an HTML CSS and JavaScript file and
a prompts MD file for the AI prompts so
let's start by sharing our idea with
chat GPT through a conversational prompt
this approach could give us a great
starting point and allow us to shape the
project and code in a more organic and
less rigid way this prompt starts with a
friendly greeting and presents the
project idea it clearly mentions the
Technologies to be used which is HTML
CSS and JavaScript and describes the
details about the desired functionality
then it instructs the AI to outline the
basic steps to get started so based on
this prompt the AI should have a broad
understanding of the projects objective
which is a great way for us to Kickstart
the project as it allows for more
creativity and ideation so I'll copy
this prompt and feed it into chat upbt
and chat upbt practically generates some
ideas and steps I can use as the basis
for instructional prompts to help build
my raffle app for instance steps 1 two
and three outline the basic steps to
follow for creating the HTML CSS and
JavaScript interactivity these look good
to me so let's go with these suggestions
to set up the core HTML CSS and
JavaScript for the app since we've
established this collaborative two-way
conversation with the AI I will reply to
it with this instructional prompt this
prompt instructs the AI to generate the
project code for steps 1 through three
of the suggested outline then it
provides specific steps on how to
structure the HTML and divide the app
into different sections making the task
clearer and easier to follow for the
design it suggest just using a vibrant
color scheme such as this value here and
similar complimentary colors for the
button States The Prompt also asks to
make the code easy to understand even
for non-coders and to add code comments
in the CSS and JavaScript to help us
understand and learn what it's doing so
let's see what chat GPT will generate
with this
prompt and good it Returns the HTML CSS
and JavaScript code for the app so first
I'll copy and paste the HTML code code
into my
project then let's dress up the page
with CSS I'll copy the CSS code and
paste it into styles.css let's run the
code and see what we've got so far good
I like the direction so far and lastly
we can't forget the most important
ingredient JavaScript so I'll copy the
JavaScript code and paste it into
script.js so let's spend some time going
over the JavaScript at the top we access
all the relevant elements on the page
that we want to interact with or display
dynamically like the form input field
and Button as well as the participant
list and winner display container and it
assigns them to variables now this line
of code here declares a variable called
participants and assigns it to an empty
array a JavaScript array is a data
structure that allows you to store
multiple values in a single variable
it's like having a collection of items
in a list in this case it stores a list
of the raffle participants and this code
pays attention to when users submit the
raffle form then all this functionality
here gets executed on the page that's
what this function keyword is for in
JavaScript functions contain a block of
code that performs a specific task or
set of instructions in this case it's
getting the entered name and assigning
it to this name variable then it's
adding or pushing the name into the
participants array and below this line
is displaying the name on the page
inside the participants list now this
syntax here that uses back tick places
each name inside P tags to create a
paragraph element and this dollar sign
curly braces syntax dynamically inserts
and displays a participant's name on the
page it's called a template literal and
the line below clears the name input
field so all of that happens with just
the form submission now just below is
the functionality for the pages draw
button the program listens for when the
button is clicked then runs this block
of code first it checks if there are
names in the participants list or more
than zero items in that array it runs
this code to randomly select and display
a raffle winner and emojis again using
the special back TI and dollar sign
curly braces syntax all right now let's
try it out I'll enter some names like
Gil then click the draw button and it
displays the winner which is Bob
congrats on your cake Bob refresh the
page and everything clears so great with
JavaScript our cake lottery app becomes
a dynamic and interactive user
experience now one thing I immediately
noticed is the spacing problem between
the input field and enter button so I'll
fix that in the CSS I'll find the
selector where we're styling the input
element with the type text right here
here and apply a bottom margin of let's
say 16 pixels and there we go now while
I'm here I also think that the label for
the name input would look better if the
text was bold so I'll update that here
in the label rule with the font weight
property and set it to the value bold
and that looks much better to me all
right next let's work on a JavaScript
challenge I'll paste it here in
script.js I want you to work on adding a
reset button that clears the participant
list and winner display the button
should allow users to start a new round
of the cake raffle and I've provided a
hint saying that the number of items in
the participants array or its length
should be equal to zero then use this
color value for the button background
and this color for its hover State this
is likely the toughest challenge you've
worked on so far and if you have a look
through the JavaScript you'll find some
lines of code that might give you a hint
of what you'll need to do for example
these two lines here and as usual feel
free to rely on chat GPT and ask it for
suggestions so take it away you've got
this and I'll catch up with you when
you're done to go over it
together all right hopefully you got
through most of the challenge if you did
amazing work now let's go over it
together first I'll work on adding the
reset button in the HTML to do that I
can copy the existing draw button and
paste it below then update this code so
that the ID is reset dash button and
that the text is reset and there's our
reset button now it doesn't look like
the other buttons yet and that's because
we need to style it with CSS and I see
that this CSS here is what's applying
the styles to the submit and draw button
it's selecting both at the same time so
I'll also have this select the reset
button by typing a comma and then the
reset button ID and good now the reset
button has the button Styles applied now
we need to apply a different background
color to the reset button so I'll create
a separate CSS rule for that that
targets the reset button ID and I'll use
the background color property to apply
the background color using this color
value here which I'll just copy and
paste into my CSS looking good and I
also provided a color for the hover
state so I'll copy that and in the CSS
I'll style the reset buttons hover State
similar to how it's styling the draw
buttons hover state with reset dash
button colon hover and then here I'll
include background color and the color
for the hover State let's try it out and
now when you hover over the reset button
you should see it change to a darker
shade of blue and it does good all right
let's move move on to the JavaScript
next first I'll work on getting a
reference to the reset button and
assigning it to a variable I see
something very similar being done here
for the draw button so I'll just copy
this line of code and update it so that
the variable name is reset button and
that it's getting the element with an ID
of reset button and I mentioned looking
through the JavaScript code and maybe
finding some hints of what you'll need
to do so I do see that this of code is
what selects the random winner and
displays the Winner's name on the page
so I might be able to do something
similar with the reset button so how
about if I just copy this entire block
of code or event listener paste it below
and update this to reset button. Adent
listener and when the reset button gets
clicked I want to clear the participants
list and the winner display area I don't
need to check if there are participants
and select a random winners so I can and
delete this and I mentioned that this
line of code might give you a hint it's
what's setting the inner HTML of the
winter display to the winner and emojis
so how about if I copy this line of code
and paste it inside the code for my
reset button and instead of setting its
inner HTML to a paragraph We want to
clear it so instead I'll set it to an
empty set of quotes and let's see what
happens I'll type a name into the field
select Tom as the winner then click the
reset button and great the winter
display area disappears from the page so
now it looks like I need to clear the
participants list looking through the
code I do see the variable for
participant list so I'll copy
participant list. HTML and I'll follow
the same pattern here set participants
list. HTML to an empty set of quotes
I'll add a couple names to the list
select the winner congrats Tom now let's
see what happens when we click reset
awesome now both the winner and
participant list are cleared now there
is one more important thing that we need
to do and if you did not think about or
implement this part that's totally okay
we need to ensure that our participants
array is truly empty because notice that
if you click draw it displays Gil as the
winner click it again it displays
treasure as the winner which is weird
because Gil and treasure do not appear
in the participants list well it turns
out that they are still being stored in
the participants array so we'll need to
clear or empty the array and in the
challenge steps I've provided a hint
saying that the number of items in the
participants array which is known as the
array's length should be equal to zero
and here in this if statement I'm seeing
participants. length and length refers
to the number of items or elements
inside an array in this case the
participants array so let's see what
happens if we set the length to zero
here in the event listener with
participants. length equals
0 Let's test it out draw a winner
congrats bear and I'll click reset that
clears the page and clicking draw should
not draw a new winner and it doesn't
good which means that worked again this
was a tough challenge so if you came up
with a solution similar to mine well
done next I'll quickly walk you through
some visual enhancements we can apply to
the page the first one is to adjust the
layout of our buttons I think the page
would look better if if the draw and
reset buttons were on the same line like
this there's different ways I might do
that so what I'll do in the HTML is
place them inside a div with the class
name button group like
so then I'll use a CSS layout technique
you saw in an earlier lesson called
flexbox to place both buttons on the
same Row first I'll select the class
button group and here I'll turn on the
special Flex boox layout with display
Flex and you can see what that did now I
want to apply a gap or a space between
the buttons and for that I'll use a CSS
property intuitively named Gap and set
it to 10 pixels and that's looking
really good to me finally let's liveen
up the page with a cake icon similar to
Google web fonts Google offers a
collection of icons called material
icons that we can easily use in our
projects so I'll ask chat GPT to give me
the code for that using this prompt here
please use Google material icons to add
a cake icon inside the H1 I'll paste
that into chat
GPT and it returns two HTML Snippets for
adding and displaying the icon first it
looks like I need to add the Google
material icon stylesheet to the HTML
with this line of code so I'll copy that
and paste it in the head section of my
HTML and then I need to modify the H1 to
include this I tag with the class
material I icon so I'll copy just that
line of code and replace this H1 in the
header with the new code all right cool
there's the cake icon next to the title
and there we have it everyone a fully
functional cake raffle app before moving
on to the next project I'd like you to
experiment with the HTML CSS and
JavaScript and tweak the functionality
to make this app truly yours for example
change the theme to a movie ticket
raffle a pizza raffle anything you'd
like and I also want you to ask chat GPT
about some of the things we've covered
or anything that you still might be
confused about as you've experienced
coding with AI gives you Endless
Possibilities it's like having your cake
and eating it too you get to create
amazing things and have a sweet time
doing it so go ahead and Delight your
friends and co-workers with a raffle
app hi there you've taken some big
strides in this course exploring the
fasc F inting world of coding and
building cool apps while leveraging
generative AI tools like chat gbt you've
had a taste of what it's like to create
something from just an idea then watch
that idea take shape even without formal
coding skills now at this point you
might feel like you've been thrown into
the deep end and maybe worried that you
don't understand everything and that
you're dealing with code that seems more
complex than you expected well rest
assured that it is 100% normal to feel
this way in fact for this course
specifically this is intentional You
Were Meant to punch above your weight in
this course and work with code or take
on challenges you don't fully understand
or seem beyond your current skill level
the goal all along has been to get you
to Dive Right into building projects and
solving problems without going the long
way of learning most things from scratch
beforehand or focusing on the code
itself now if you feel like you need to
get a firmer grasp or dive deeper into
the technical details of coding and a
lot of what you've been working with so
far then script rmba front and developer
career path is the perfect place to
learn more and take that next step on
your coding and building Journey we
designed this curriculum to deepen your
knowledge of HTML CSS JavaScript react
and more with 13 modules filled with
interactive coding challenges and over
15 real world projects that you will
build yourself from scratch with the
opportunity to get code reviews from the
scrimba community if you'd like to check
it out or join at any time visit the
frontend developer career path on the
scrimba site or click on this image to
head over to it now I'll see you back
soon to keep on
building we are going to navigate an
essential skill for any Builder and
coder debugging and getting feedback to
improve your code and we'll use chat gbt
to help guide us through this we're
going to use this real rewards project
which is a simple page that gives you a
50% discount on movie tickets when you
enter the promo code have to structure
the page we have an H1 element and a
paragraph element to display the final
price then below a div with a ID app
containing a form element where users
can enter and submit their promo code
over in the JavaScript we are first
getting elements from the HTML like the
promo code input field the paragraph
displaying the final ticket price and
the promo code form and assigning them
to variables The Base ticket price is
set to
the script then displays this price in
the final price element when the page
loads and right below the function
applyed discount calculates the final
price based on the entered promo code if
the promo code the user enters is equal
to half then the discount rate is set to
0.5 or 50% otherwise it remains zero and
no discount gets applied the function
then calculates the final price by
subtracting the discount from the base
price and returns a final price and this
code here runs when the user submits a
promo code so when the form is submitted
this code retrieves the entered promo
code and calculates the final price by
running or calling this apply discount
function which is this code here and
then it checks if the final price is
less than the base price meaning a valid
discount was applied then the script
updates and displays the new price here
otherwise if no valid discount was
applied the script sets the placeholder
text in the input field to display the
message in valid promo code and this
line here clears the input field I
totally understand if there's code here
that you don't quite get or that is
still confusing to you I don't want you
to feel like you need to understand
everything in this Javascript file the
purpose of this lesson is to help you
get feedback improve and understand your
code a little bit better with the help
of chat gbt now this project is far from
perfect or even production ready in fact
when you first run it notice how we're
getting a JavaScript error in the
console so let's look at some ways we
can debug and improve the JavaScript
with the help of chubbt now debugging
might sound a bit intimidating at first
but it's just the process of identifying
and removing errors or bugs from your
code with chat gbt you can more easily
troubleshoot these errors it can point
out syntax and logic errors or even
suggest better practices to prevent bugs
in the future so here's an example of
how you might prompt chat TBT for
debugging you can provide a description
of the issue paste your code into the
chat and it will help identify possible
problems so for example here I'm saying
that I'm having an issue running my
JavaScript code and then I'm providing
the airor message I'm getting which is
the message that appears in the console
and then I say please help me understand
what's wrong so I'll submit this prompt
to chat GPT and here I see that this
typically occurs when you're attempting
to manipulate an element that doesn't
exist or hasn't been properly accessed
and then I see more instructions here
for example ensure that your JavaScript
code is running after the HTML document
has finished loading ah so here I see
that you can achieve this by placing
your JavaScript code at the bottom of
the HTML file just before the closing
body tag looking at the HTML I see that
the script tag is in the head tag so
that is indeed what's causing the
problem so I'll move my script tag just
above the closing body tag like so and
when I run the code I see that the air
no longer appears in the console great
testing the form now I see that I'm not
able to submit a promo code notice how
clicking the apply discount button
immediately refreshes the page
preventing a discount to be applied as
expected so I'll turn to chat GPT with
this prompt which says I'm having issues
with my JavaScript code submitting the
promo form refreshes the page and does
not run the following code as a expected
in this case I'm placing the code to
evaluate within triple back ticks to
visually separate the code from the
surrounding text and indicate that it
should be treated as code this can also
make it easier for human readers to
identify the code improving the overall
readability of the prompt and for the AI
itself it might help separate our
instructions from the context you might
also see this done with hash symbols or
quotes for example now in many cases you
don't even need to place your code with
than quotes hash symbols or back ticks
chat gbt is likely to figure it out so
I'll copy this prompt and paste it into
chat GPT and it looks like the
JavaScript is missing a method to
prevent the default form submission
behavior and that's this method here
event.prevent default so let me add that
line of code here in my promo form event
listener right at the top like this this
ensures that the default form submission
behavior is is cancelled so now when I
enter a promo code and submit the form
the JavaScript code runs without
refreshing the page allowing the promo
code to be applied and display the final
price but testing it again it looks like
the discount gets applied to the base
price no matter what text or promo code
you enter so I'm going to challenge you
to debug and fix this with the help of
chat GPT the challenge is to use chat
GPT to debug the apply discount function
so I want you to head over to chat GPT
and provide it with this prompt and
include the code to debug within the
hash symbols then evaluate chat gpt's
response and fix the code using what it
suggests so pause me now and give this a
go okay hopefully you got it to work
I'll give it a go by including my apply
discount function here within the hash
symbols then copying this prompt and
feeding it to chbt
and here I see that the issue is in the
conditional statement it looks like
instead of a comparison operator which
is this triple equal sign I'm using the
assignment operator or only an equal
sign to compare the user code with the
string half and this is what's leading
to the incorrect behavior and then to
fix the problem I need to change the
assignment operator to the equality
operator and I see an example of that
here in the updated code all right this
doesn't seem too bad so over in the
JavaScript I'll update this line here to
if user code triple equal sign half
using the triple equals for comparison
ensures that the value of user code is
compared to the string half and if they
are strictly equal then the discount
rate will be set to 0.5 or 50% otherwise
it remains zero or no discount gets
applied I'll test it out I see that the
Base ticket price is $50 now I'll enter
the promo code have and all caps click
apply discount and great the final
ticket price is indeed 50% off or $25 so
now the code seems to be working as
expected all right once your code runs
without errors you might want to make it
more efficient or readable and this is
where chat GPT truly shines with its
ability to generate code you can ask
chat GPT for more efficient modern and
elegant Solutions or different
approaches to a problem a prompt you can
use for code Improvement might look like
this it says that this JavaScript code
works as expected but I think it could
be made more efficient and modern please
provide a more streamlined and upto-date
version of this code then I'll paste all
of my JavaScript code here and chat gbt
will evaluate it and give me some
suggestions all right so here I see that
it suggests replacing the VAR keyword
with const which can help avoid
accidental reassignments and bugs in the
code and it simplified the applied
discount function using a conditional
turn area operator to assign the
discount rate based on the user code
that's this code here which is another
more concise way to write an IFL
statement and I see that it also
suggested using Arrow functions which is
another way to write functions using a
shorter syntax so the JavaScript does
seem more efficient with modern features
that can help prevent bugs in the future
and I could use this code and push my
project live but I think I'll ask for
more feedback on my original code as
with any learning and building process
feedback is key and AIS like chat GPT
can provide that too with its immense
knowledge of coding conventions and
standards chat gbt can give you valuable
feedback on your code structure syntax
and even style so this time we're going
to take advantage of the role playing
prompting approach to request feedback
I'm telling chat chbt you are a senior
developer reviewing my JavaScript code
before I ship it to production please
provide feedback on how I can improve
this code make it more maintainable and
handle cases where a user enters the
promo code in lowercase because notice
that if you enter the promo code half in
all lowercase the discount doesn't get
applied but I think that users should
still get the discount even if they type
the promo code in all lowercase so my
senior developer here is going to help
me out with that below I'll paste all my
JavaScript
code then submit this prompt to chat GPT
and here I see a lot of valuable
feedback and suggestions for example it
suggests using descriptive variable
names to convey their purpose and
meaning better and to convert the base
price value to a numeric value versus a
string and that's going to help prevent
calculation errors then to handle cases
where a user enters the promo code in
all lowercase it says that I can convert
the user code to uppercase and compare
it to an all uppercase version of the
promo code this two uppercase method
converts text to all uppercase letters
this looks good to me so I'll copy this
new JavaScript code snippet and replace
all the code in my script.js file with
this new JavaScript overall I think that
this feedback makes the code more
functional organized and maintainable
for example I even see that it suggested
moving the logic for applying the
discount and determining the final price
into two separate functions and then
only referencing or running the handle
form submission function here when the
form gets submitted which makes the code
easier to understand and maintain I'll
run all this latest code and test it out
the ticket price is $50 I'll type half
in all lowercase and good the discount
gets applied so now the final price is
$25 and if I enter an invalid code such
as test I get the message invalid promo
code awesome now don't worry if you're
still confused about or don't understand
a lot of this code like always spend
some time asking chat upbt to give you
more details about anything you like to
learn more about remember coding isn't
always about making things work it's an
iterative process so it's perfectly okay
and normal to encounter bugs and
problems in your code it's all part of
the journey and with tools like chubbt
by your side you'll be well equipped to
tackle these challenges
headon
all right let's get ready to turn up the
volume on our coding skills and build a
drum kit web app with the guidance of
chat upbt as usual HTML will form the
structure of our drum kit CSS will give
it a Sleek look and JavaScript will add
exciting interactive elements and play
real drum sounds so grab your virtual
drumsticks and let's hit it the project
contains the usual HTML CSS and
JavaScript files and this time I've
included a folder named sounds that
contains several audio files in the wave
format we are going to take this step by
step so first we'll ask the AI to
Kickstart this project let's see how we
can code a button that when clicked
triggers a kick drum sound I'll use this
instructional prompt that provides a
clear task for the AI to build a simple
drumkit app using HTML CSS and
JavaScript and I want to start with only
one button that when clicked should play
a drum sound and the button should
appear centered on screen below I've
provided some context about the sound
file like its name and location and I've
learned that HTML has a handy audio tag
which is used to embed and load sound
files in your page so I'm asking it to
use the audio element for the sound file
and as usual I want code comments to
help me understand each part of the code
so I'll paste this prompt into chat gbt
and let's check out its response okay
first it suggests the project directory
structure which we've already set up
just like this
and here's the HTML which I'll copy and
paste into my project I see that it has
a container div with a kick button
inside it and below is the audio element
to preload the kick. wve sound file so
let's add the CSS next which I see is
using that special flexbox layout
feature you've seen before to Center the
button on the page so I'll add this CSS
to my project and finally copy the
JavaScript and paste it into script.js
the JavaScript gets the kick button
element and assigns it to the const
variable kick button then it gets the
kick sounds audio element and stores it
in the variable kick sound then below
the code pays close attention to when
the kick button gets clicked so when the
user clicks it it runs this code to play
the kick sound in JavaScript this play
method is used to start playing media
like audio and kick sound. current time
equals 0 makes the audio start playing
from the beginning all right so let's
get to the moment you've been waiting
for and try it out I'll click on the
kick
button and great the kick sound plays
before we get to adding more drum sounds
I want you to give your drum app a title
so here's your challenge come up with a
cool name for your drumkit app and
display it in a heading and then Center
the heading on the page with CSS so
pause me now and give that a
go all right here we go I'll add an H1
element here to create my pages main
heading and I'll give my drum kit app a
cool name like Groove kit there we go
now to center it on the page I'll select
the H1 here in the CSS and set its
textalign property to Center and while
I'm here I'll adjust the CSS for the
container so that there isn't as much of
a gap between the heading and the button
I'll get rid of this align items and
height properties since we don't really
need them and then how about giving the
container a top margin of 30 pixels that
looks much better all right let's move
on to your next challenge we are going
to expand our drum kit your challenge is
to create a new button for the ride drum
sound you'll need to write the button
tag the audio tag and the JavaScript
code to make it play when clicked and be
sure to use the existing HTML and
JavaScript code as a reference so pause
me now and work on this challenge
all right if you were able to add and
play The Ride drum sound great work now
let's work on it together first to add
the right button and play The Ride sound
I can follow the same pattern use for
the kick button and sound I'll copy this
kick button and paste a new button
element below then update the ID to ride
and the button text to ride and then
I'll copy the audio element for the kick
sound and update this ID to ride Das
sound and I want the source to point to
the file ride. wve all right that should
be it for the HTML now let's move on to
the JavaScript first I'll retrieve the
ride button element and assign it to a
variable so I'll copy the line for the
kick button and update the variable name
here to ride button which will select
the element with the ID
ride and I'll get the ride sound element
in the same way I'll update this
variable name to ride sound and get the
element with the ID r- sound finally to
play the right sound when the right
button is clicked I'll copy this code
block here paste it below and then
update this code block so that it pays
attention to the ride button and when
the ride button is clicked I want to
play the ride sound so I'll change this
here to rid sound. current time equals 0
and then to actually play play it I'll
update this to rid sound. playay all
right let's give it a
try all right cool now we're able to
play both the kick and ride sounds we
are making good progress so now we'll
ask the AI to make our drum kit more
interactive I wanted to play drum sounds
using my keyboard and not just with
button clicks for example pressing the a
key on my keyboard plays the kick sound
and the S key the right sound so next
I'll prompt the AI to extend the drum
kit app by triggering the kick sound
when the a keyboard key is pressed so
let's start with that and see what chat
GPT comes up with all right so it gives
me the modified JavaScript and I'll only
copy this new code block at the bottom
and add it to my Javascript file so now
the JavaScript program is paying
attention to or listening for key
presses on the page this code is saying
when a key is pressed down anywhere on
the page do the following actions in
this case it uses an if statement to
check which key was pressed so if the
Pressed key is a then it plays the kick
sound so now I can press my a key to
play the kick
sound next how about you work on
updating this JavaScript to play The
Ride sound file whenever the S key is
pressed so pause me now and go for
it
all right here we go to play the right
sound when the S key is pressed I'll
copy this if statement paste a new one
below and I'll update this to else if so
if the Pressed key is s it's going to
play the ride sound so I'll update this
to rid sound. current time equals 0 and
rid sound. playay I'll test it
out and good that worked let's keep the
Beats
coming so your challenge is to complete
the drum kit app by adding the button
and audio elements for the snare Tom and
high hat sounds you'll also need to
update the JavaScript so that clicking
each button will play the corresponding
sound and then play each sound when
pressing a specific key and the keys to
press are up to you so take your time
with this and I'll meet you back up when
you're done to go over
it okay hopefully you got all your drum
sounds to play and even jammed out for a
bit now let's work through these I don't
want you to have to watch me type every
button audio tag and JavaScript code so
I'll paste all the remaining button and
audio elements here in the HTML we have
our button elements and now the audio
tags then in the JavaScript I'll paste
in the variables for the buttons and
then the three audio elements next I'll
paste the event listeners for the three
buttons right
here and finally the else if statements
for each key press and notice how the
buttons overflow their containers and
we're not able to view them all at once
on the page I can fix this with CSS by
wrapping the buttons onto new lines
whenever there's not enough space for
the buttons to all fit on one or even
two lines here in the container rule so
I'll wrap them with the flex wrap
property which is also a special flexbox
property then set the value to wrap and
I also want to space them out by adding
a gap between each so I'll use the Gap
property and set a 20 pixel Gap all
right much better now the buttons are
all nicely spaced out and we can see
them all at once on the screen they even
stack and display as a column on narrow
screens now I'll test my latest changes
with a quick jam
session hopefully you enjoyed that it
seems like everything is working great
now while building this project we
duplicated a lot of code for example the
JavaScript that plays a specific drum
sound when its corresponding button is
clicked and the code for playing sounds
when a key is pressed and we're not
worried too much about duplicate code
right now while learning to build
projects but repetitive code like this
can often be replaced with more
efficient and maintainable code so the
last step you might do is ask chat GPT
for help updating your code so that it's
more concise readable and maintainable
with a prompt like this you can say
please update this JavaScript code so
that it's more concise and maintainable
and then include your JavaScript code
here and this will likely generate new
code that might seem a bit too complex
and difficult to understand right now so
let's not worry about that and stick
with our original code all right so
you've just built a drumkit app with
interactive elements connected them to
sounds and made the interface respond to
both mouse and keyboard inputs I think
now is a great time to show this off to
friends and colleagues you can also
customize the CSS and even add different
sounds to your app such as the Boom Clap
and open hat files included in the
sounds folder and one last thing why
don't programmers like nature because it
has too many
bugs and with that I'll show myself out
our work here is done let's move
on we've been creating some cool
projects using HTML CSS and JavaScript
with chat gbt so now it's time to
Showcase these to the world world I'm
going to introduce you to a remarkably
simple way to deploy and share your
projects using a service called netlify
so let's Jump Right In First up let me
show you how to download the code from a
scrim onto your computer first click on
the gear icon in the bottom right corner
of your scrim then click download as zip
and that's going to download a zip file
to your computer unzip the file and
you'll see your project files inside a
folder in the folder you might see some
new unfamiliar files like readme MD
package.json and another named V.C
config.js go ahead and delete those
files because you're not going to need
them I also suggest renaming your
project folder to help you keep track of
it and now you're ready to deploy your
project with netlify netlify is simple
to use even for non-coders and perfect
for our needs it offers free hosting for
personal projects which makes it a great
choice and we'll focus on netfi drag and
drop feature so head over to netlify.com
or click on this image to visit the site
and create a free account you can simply
use your email to sign up or if you
happen to have an account with a service
or platform like GitHub or gitlab you
can use it to sign up with your account
all set up you can deploy your first
site in minutes and you'll be amazed at
how simple this is on your netlify
dashboard you'll see a section titled
sites then under the add new site
dropdown select deploy manually and
here's where the magic of dragon drop
comes into play you take your project
folder then drag and drop it right into
this area where it says drag and drop
your site output folder here and that's
it no complex configurations no code
just drag and drop netlify will do its
thing and your site will be live on the
web within moments you'll see that
netlify provides you with a unique URL
where you or anyone can access your site
click on it and you'll see your project
live on the web and from here sharing
your project is as easy as sharing this
URL that netlify provides so now what
happens when you want to make changes to
your project after it's been deployed
well netfi makes this easy too after
making changes to your project you only
need to drag and drop the updated
project folder onto the netlify
dashboard here under deploys and netlify
will automatically update your site with
the new changes the URL for your project
stays the same so there's no need to
reshare a new link so just remember that
every time you make a change in your
local project files you'll need to
re-upload the entire project folder to
netlify to ensure that your live site
stays in sync with a project on your
computer and there you have it deploying
and sharing your projects is pretty much
a breeze with netlify so don't hesitate
to get your work out there in fact how
about you share a project you built in
this course with peers by posting the
project link on the today I did Discord
Channel clicking on this image will take
you right to that channel remember
building is only half the fun sharing
your Creations is where the magic truly
happens
and just like that we've reached the end
of this section where we started to
bridge the gap between learning to code
and building tangible projects with HTML
CSS and JavaScript all while unlocking
the potential of AI so nice work we
kicked it off with the basics and some
simple elements but before we knew it we
were building functional interactive
projects while learning how to frame
effective prompts and debug and refine
our code with the help of AI so with the
skills and AI know how you've now got
under your belt you're well equipped to
tackle bigger more complex projects
you've come a long way and the exciting
part is that this is still just the
beginning this course is a living
iterative project much like the evolving
field of AI itself I'll be adding more
sections to the course featuring new
more complex projects that will allow
you to stretch your newly acquired
skills even further so I'd really
appreciate sharing your thoughts
feedback and suggestions about this
course and any ideas for projects you'd
like to build in the future sections of
this course clicking on this image right
here will take you directly to a quick
feedback form in the meantime I hope you
continue to explore and build with AI so
I'll see you back soon and we look
forward to checking out your projects
happy
building hello again brilliant Builders
we've spent some time together building
wonderful projects and dipping our toes
into the world of HTML CSS and
JavaScript all with the help of AI but
we're just getting started in this
section we'll be transforming Next Level
project ideas into reality all while
keeping the building and learning
process fun and interactive remember
that the goal is to help you build
projects with the magic of AI while not
getting lost in the weeds of
technicalities so let's take a peek at
what's in store for you first you'll
build your own version of the classic
whack-a-mole game it's called face bomp
and it will surely put a smile on
everyone's face then you'll build an
interactive project slideshow perfect
for a personal portfolio website
following that we'll put together a
personal homepage where you'll showcase
all your fantastic AI assisted projects
and tell the world a little about
yourself and your skills and that's just
the beginning we are also diving into
building Chrome extensions you'll create
a shopping wishlist extension called
Snap stash you'll also design and build
a Smart Home Mobile interface and even
learn how to transform it into a mobile
friendly app that users can launch from
their devices home screen and to make
storing and sharing your projects easier
I'll guide you through adding your
project s to a platform called GitHub
finally to wrap up this section I'll
teach you how to use GitHub and netlify
together to automate how you deploy your
project updates like the previous
section of this course you may at times
feel like you're in unfamiliar territory
and worry that you're not understanding
everything that's going on in the code
but rest assured that this is
intentional as I've mentioned before
this course encourages you to stretch
beyond your comfort zone diving into
code or challenges that might seem
Advanced for your current skill set we
want you to Dive Right into building
cool stuff without going the long way of
learning everything from scratch with AI
at your side you can quickly get off the
ground with plain conversational English
and then gradually become more technical
as you put together simple apps so let's
launch right into this section to
continue exploring the power of AI and
keep on building before you do take a
moment to let your scribo colleagues
know that you're starting this section
in the today I will Discord Channel
click on this image to jump right into
the
channel every ever heard of or played
the game whack-a-mole well we're about
to build a version of the game with a
personal spin calling it face bump we'll
kick off this section by recreating this
classic tactile game into a digital
experience using HTML CSS and JavaScript
so the idea is pretty straightforward
instead of moles we're using photos
maybe even one of you or your friends
and the challenge is to catch and bump
the photo every time it appears just
like in the classic game the game will
even include a timer a score display and
images that pop in and out at random and
to speed up the process we'll get some
help from chat GPT let's kick things off
with a prompt here to help create the
structure of the game in the prompt I
provide a brief description of the game
and the type of code I'll need for it I
initially want to display the game's
title a start button a score display and
a timer and the game will display a
final message to the player when it ends
so I'm requesting a placeholder element
for the message and finally keeping with
the wack-a-mole style I'd like a game
board with six holes where the images
will pop in and out of I even provided
the image file name which is
photo.png all right now I'll copy and
paste this prompt into chat gbt and
let's see what we get back and here's
the HTML for our game so I'll copy the
code and paste it into
index.html and good it looks like it has
all the elements I requested the title
start button a score display here I see
a timer the message div and the game
board with the image slots or holes and
all six images point to
photo.png which is this image here great
all the images are displaying correctly
now let's add some style to the
game I'll use this next prompt which
asks chbt to style the game using a
bright blue theme with background
gradients and complimentary Three Shades
for the game controls and holes and I
want the holes to be circular and the
photos to have a popping in andout
effect I'd also like to place the holes
on a grid and Center each item inside
its hole all right fingers crossed let's
feed this prompt to chat gbt and see if
it can work some magic for us okay I'll
copy the CSS and paste it into
styles.css and I can see that this is
already starting to look good so let's
go over the CSS here we have some styles
that you've likely seen before for the
body H1 the button and the score timer
and game board elements as well as the
holes where the images will pop in and
out of now one thing that caught my eye
is that it's using CSS grid to lay out
the holes in the game board grid is a
super powerful CSS layout system for
placing items in rows and columns and I
see that it's creating three columns
here each 150 pixels wide using this
repeat function and it's adding a 20
pixel gap between each hole to space
them out all right so chat gbt has given
us a visually pleasing design for the
most part I see the gradient background
and a neat grid layout for our image
slots so now let's spend some time
customizing the design of the game so
first up let's liveen up the Page by
adding a winking face emoji to the title
here in end
index.html just like that there we go
and I also want to make the button
Corners rounded which I can do in
styles.css here in the button rule using
the Border radius property I'll set it
to five pixels and that looks good I
also feel like the score needs to stand
out so let's make it larger by
increasing its font size so here in the
score rule I see that the font size is
being set using the CSS REM unit which
might be new to you rem stands for root
M don't worry too much about it it's
just a different more flexible and
scalable way to set font sizes and other
properties with CSS you can bump up the
value and set it to two RAM for example
and that would look good but we've been
using pixel units this whole time so
let's just stick with that here I'll set
the font size of score to 32 pixels and
I also want to update the mark margins
for the score so that it has a top and
bottom margin of 20 pixels so I'll
replace the margin top property with
just margin and as you've learned in
previous projects with this shorthand
the first value sets the top and bottom
margin so we'll leave that as 20 pixels
and the second value sets the left and
right margins which I'll set to zero and
while we're here let's also adjust the
timer's font size so here in the timer
rule I'll set the font size to a value
like 24 pixels and let's create more
space between the timer and the game
board below it so I'll replace margin
top with margin bottom 20 pixels a
subtle change but this is looking much
better to me and if you're curious
before we move on I want you to pause me
and ask chbt to explain the CSS REM unit
in more detail go ahead I'll wait all
right so now it looks like we'll need to
adjust the images in the game board
holes I'll have you make these changes
with a
challenge here here's what we'll need to
do first let's make the game more
challenging by making the image Target
smaller because currently the images are
as wide and as tall as the holes so I
want you to resize them to be 55% of the
width and height of their hole then
you'll notice that the images are
initially squared but they need to be
circular you've done this before so go
ahead and update the CSS to make the
images perfectly rounded and here's an
important adjustment you'll need to make
all the images are currently visible by
default but they all need to be
initially hidden from view so notice in
this CSS rule how this transform
property uses a CSS scale function to
scale or increase the size of an image
inside an active hole to the value 1.1
which is 100% of its size so I want you
to think about how you might use this
property here in the CSS rule that
Styles an image within a whole element
to to hide or scale them out of view so
go ahead and pause the scrim now and
work through this challenge I'll catch
up with you soon to go over the solution
you've got
this all right hopefully you got that so
first the images are currently 100% the
width and height of their parent whole
element so to resize the images to be
55% of the width and height of their
hole I'll update the width property to
55% and the height property to
55% and there we go as I mentioned the
images are initially squared so to make
them perfectly rounded I'll use the
Border radius property and set it to the
value 50% which does in fact make them
perfectly rounded within their hole
awesome okay so now how do we set the
initial scale of an image to make it
invisible for that I'll use the
transform property here in the whole
image rule and like in here use the
scale function to set the initial scale
of the image to zero just like that so
essentially the base style for the image
inside a whole class makes it invisible
as you can see here the images are gone
but as you'll see later when the whole
element also has an active class the
image will enlarge smoothly to 110% of
its size suggesting some sort of active
State for the image which is when a
player will be able to whack or face
bump it and this transition property
adds a smooth transition effect on the
transform property so when the scale of
the image changes it will animate over a
duration of 0.2 seconds and ease in Out
means that the animation starts and ends
slowly and speeds up in the middle so if
you've successfully worked through these
steps and came up with a similar
solution nice work and now the real fun
begins with JavaScript we'll make the
images pop in and out from their hole
keep track of the score and manage the
countdown timer so I'll add a third
prompt that instructs chat gbt to
implement these desired features with
JavaScript to create that whacka effect
the images should appear and then
disappear into their holes and I want it
to happen at random intervals to make
the game interesting when a player
clicks on an image the player score
should increase by one and will create a
30 second countdown timer which starts
immediately after clicking the start
button then the game should end when the
timer reaches zero also when the game
ends I want to display a fun and witty
message based on the player score and
let users easily Play Again by clicking
the start button and as always I'd like
code comments to help me understand the
JavaScript logic all right so here you
go chat GPT do your thing and let's see
what chat GPT came up with by copying
the JavaScript code and pasting it into
script.js it looks like this is quite a
bit of code so let's have a look at the
top I see that it's selecting elements
from the HTML like the start button the
score display the timer the message
display and the holes and then I see
some variables holding information like
the current score the desired time for
the timer whether the game started as
well as the current time in the
countdown and this function here
generates a random time interval to
display the images using a desired Min
and max value and it looks like the code
below is used to display the images in
the holes first it makes sure that no
holes are active with visible images
then it selects holes randomly for the
images to pop in and out of and then it
applies the active class we looked at
earlier in the CSS which is this class
here which gives the image the effect
that it's popping out of the hole and
here I see that the time intervals will
be chosen randomly between 500 and, 1500
milliseconds or between half a second
and 1.5 seconds and then after the set
random time it hides the image by
removing the active class here and if
the game is still playing or the
countdown hasn't hit zero yet it
continues the game by displaying the
next image again and again until the
time gets to zero all right and this
function is the logic that starts the
game and updates the countdown and
current score it also stops the game
when the time reaches zero and displays
a message below is the event listener
that starts the game when the player
clicks the start button and then we have
another event listener for clicking on
the images and increasing the score and
finally this function is what's used to
return a fun message based on the score
so if the score is equal to zero we get
this message and players will get a
different message if they score less
than 10 less than 20 or 20 points or
more all right that was a lot of code to
go over and I completely understand if a
lot of this seems a little bit confusing
to you or very confusing for you right
now it's totally normal so what I want
you to do is pause me right now if you
feel like you need to take a moment to
ask chat gbt to explain any of the code
that you don't quite understand or want
to learn more about all right now let's
see what we've got by testing the game
I'll click Start game and then cool my
pesky photo is popping up randomly which
can be challenging at times I'll try to
get as many face boms as
possible after 30 seconds the game is
over I scored 12 points so the message I
get is you getting good at this cool now
I did notice an issue with the countdown
timer text here which we'll get to and
fix shortly and I also just thought of a
cool effect we can apply to the holes on
the game board we can make the Shadows
appear inside the holes instead of
outside to give each hole the appearance
of depth the Box Shadow property in CSS
is what adds a shadow effect to an
element so this property is applying a
shadow to each hole and by adding the
inset keyword at the start of the Box
Shadow value like so effectively creates
an inner Shadow which gives each hole an
appearance of being indented into the
page and it creates a subtle depth
effect all right this is looking good
and it seems like we're mostly set up
with all the game
mechanics let's keep it going by adding
some enhancements to our face bump game
first when a player hovers over an image
with their Mouse I want the cursor to
change to the usual pointer or hand icon
to indicate the image is clickable or
interactive we can do that pretty easily
in the CSS here in the rule that selects
an image that's inside an element with
the class hole using the cursor property
and setting it to the value pointer and
now when we hover over an image we see
the pointer as the cursor good all right
next just for an Added Touch let's see
how we can make the image display a
bumped or whack effect when clicked I
think applying a bright red border
around it might do the trick so I'll ask
chat GPT to help me with that using this
prompt I'd like it to update the
necessary code to apply a red border to
an image only when clicked so let's feed
this into chat
gbt and I get back some new code it
looks like we need to modify the event
listener for clicking on images using
this updated JavaScript code so I'll
copy this code snippet then scroll down
to the event listener for clicking on
images right here and replace this
entire code block with the new code so
here I see that it adds the class
clicked to a clicked image then removes
it here after a delay of 300
milliseconds chat GPT also gives me the
CSS to apply the red border to an image
with the class clicked so I'll copy this
code snippet and paste it at the bottom
of styles.css I think I'll customize it
slightly I'll make the Border thicker by
changing it to four pixels and making
the color brighter with the value tomato
which is my favorite CSS color now let's
go ahead and test the latest changes
I'll start the game and click on an
image to bump it and there we have it a
bright red borderer to enhance the
player experience a simple yet effective
way to add some feedback for the player
all right so now how about some
JavaScript challenges to enhance the
interactivity of the game I'll include
the first challenge here just above the
function that starts the game so here in
the start game function I want you to
update the start button to display the
text playing when a user clicks it to
start the game and remember that you'll
need to set the button text back to
start game when the game ends so look
closely at the code in this function as
you'll find some hints on how to do this
pause me now and give it a
go all right hopefully you were able to
make this happen now I'll show you one
solution so here in the start game
function I see some code being used to
set the text content of an element like
the score display and the time display I
noticed that the start button is being
referenced here so to update the start
button text when the game starts I can
write start button. text content and set
it equal to the text playing dot dot dot
all right let's try it out when I click
the start button yes the text changes to
playing good so now we need to change
the button text back to start game when
the game ends and this is the code that
handles the game when the time is up so
it seems like I can do something very
similar here with start button. text
content equals the string start
game I'll test it out in fact to speed
things up for us I'll change the
countdown timer to be 5 Seconds instead
of 30 seconds
here and let's see I'll click Start game
the button text changes to playing and
then after 5 Seconds good it Chang
changes back to start game next let's
work on fixing the countdown timer
you've probably noticed that it's
repeating the words time left and
seconds this shouldn't be too
challenging to fix one way to fix this
would be to update the time display
variable to reference the div with the
ID timer instead of only the span
element with the ID time so back in the
JavaScript we'll say get element by ID
timer and then it should initially
display time left followed by the time
with this line here in fact I'd prefer
if we don't display the word seconds so
I'll get rid of that Al together and
we'll display the same text and time
during the countdown here in this line
so I'll just make the same change here
and let's also remove the word seconds
from the
HTML all right let's try it out I'll
click Start game and there we go the
countdown timer is looking much better
and I think it would be better if we
replace the time entirely with the final
message once the countdown hits zero and
the game ends so over in the JavaScript
let's look for the code that ends the
game when the time is up right here and
then I can replace message display.
textcontent with time display.
textcontent equals The Returned message
and now I can even delete the HTML for
the message here which is the div with
the ID message as well as the JavaScript
variable for it which is this one here
message
display Let's test it out I'll click
Start game the counter is still at 5
seconds and when the game ends the time
is replaced with the message great that
looks much better next up no game is
complete without cool sound effects so
in our final challenge you're going to
take this game to the next level by
playing a sound effect each time the
player whacks or bumps a face photo to
gain a point I'll add the steps for this
challenge here in
script.js you'll notice that I've
included some sound files here in the
sounds folder so first I want you to
embed this bump. wve sound file in the
HTML and then you'll update the
JavaScript to play the bump. wve sound
each time a player clicks on a photo you
did something very similar in the
previous section of this course where we
built the drumkit app so you can
reference the code from that project if
needed so pause me now and go for
it all right hopefully that went well
and that you were able to play the bump
sound effect now let's go over one way
to do it first I'll embed the bump. wve
sound file here in
index.html as we did in the drumkit
project I'll use the audio element for
that I'll give this audio element an ID
of bump- sound and then I need to set
the source to that wave file which is in
the sounds folder so I'll say sounds
slash bump. wve okay that's good to go
if you got this part awesome next one
very important step is that I need to
select the audio element with the ID BMP
sound here in the
JavaScript so let me add a section here
to indicate that this is where we select
audio elements for sounds and then here
I'll declare a new variable on name BM
sound so I can say document. getet
element by ID and specify the ID BMP Das
sound all right now I need to head over
to the event listener for clicking on
images right here and as you've learned
this block of code handles everything
that happens when a player clicks on a
photo like update the score and apply
the red border this is where we'll also
play the bump sound effect so first I'll
reference the bump sound variable then
call the current time property on it as
we've done before and set it to zero
which makes the audio start playing from
the beginning and then below bump sound.
playay is going to start playing the
audio okay let's test it
out and it works that is super cool so
now how about playing a sound effect
when the game ends even better we'll
play a different sound based on how the
player scored in the sounds folder I
have two more sound files game and. wve
and game and highwave so let's first
embed these in
index.html just like the bum sound in
fact I'll just copy this audio element
here paste the new one below and update
the ID to end- sound and the source
value to sounds SL
gamewave and I'll do the same name for
the high score sound update the ID to
high- sound and the source to sounds
slame and uncore
highwave all right now I can select them
with JavaScript and assign them to
variables so that we can play The Sounds
I'll copy this line here paste it below
and update the variable name to end
sound and this will get the element with
the ID and- sound let's do the same for
high sound
I'll name this variable high sound and
have it get the element with the ID high
sound we know that the start game
function handles all the functionality
to start the game and display the score
and countdown and we also work with this
code block here which ends the game when
the time is up or when time is equal to
zero so first I'll play the end sound
here and I can do that with end sound.
playay Okay so let me test this I'll
update the time to just 3
seconds and here we
go all right excellent that worked so
now let's wrap up this epic game project
with a challenge I'll add the challenge
here in
script.js I want you to update this code
so that it plays the high sound remember
that's this game _ wave file only if the
player score is higher than nine
otherwise play the regular end sound if
the score is nine or less so pause me
now and go for
it all right hopefully you were able to
make this work now let's go over how I
might do it so first to play the high
sound if the player score is greater
than nine I can use a if statement to do
that which we've done before so I'll
replace n sound. playay with an if
statement where we'll say if the value
of score is greater than nine play the
high sound with high sound. playay and
then we'll use the L statement to play
the end sound if the score is nine or
less with end sound. playay if you
figured this part out amazing job you
should be super proud all right so now
all that is left is to try it out I'll
change the timer back to to 30 seconds
and let's go for it okay here we go I'll
start the
game bump some photos oh this is pretty
tricky oh it looks like I got the high
score all right I scored more than nine
points so I got the high score sound
which is great now I'll quickly test the
n Sound by scoring less than nine
points and good our code works perfectly
this was just for testing but if you'd
like you can update the high score
values here so for example in the get
message function anything greater than
20 gives you this wow you're a face bomp
Champion so let's update the code so
that that high score sound plays when
the player scores more than 20 points
and you can set it to whatever score
you'd like also another more concise way
you might write this same expression is
using javascript's Turner operator like
this
type score is greater than 20 followed
by a question mark and if the score is
greater than 20 the high sound will play
with high sound. playay then type Aon
and if the score is 20 or less we'll
play the end sound with end sound.
playay and this should work in the same
exact way so wonderful you've just built
face bump a fun and engaging game using
HTML CSS and JavaScript we've covered a
lot of ground here so be super super
proud of yourself now before we head off
to the next project remember that this
is your foundation for this game you can
expand upon face Bomb by introducing new
features it's all up to you and I want
you to take that next step by
customizing the game and making it your
own for example upload your own images
for a more personalized experience it
can be your photo or your friend's photo
I also want you to update the game
colors and maybe write some custom
messages for when the game ends and
don't forget to share your Solution by
posting it in the today I did channel so
that'll do it for this project amazing
work let's keep
building all right let's continue by
building an interactive image slideshow
that displays different project images
and descriptions and it will be flexible
so that you can add it to a website for
example to let you users easily browse
through projects you've built or
anything you want to showcase and as
usual we'll collaborate with chat GPT to
make it happen using HTML CSS and
JavaScript so get ready to Showcase your
projects in style and let's get to it I
already included HTML CSS and JavaScript
files for the project along with three
images for the slideshow which can be
found here in the images folder so we'll
Dive Right In and prompt chat gbt with
our requirements we'll try to get most
of the image slideshow built in one shot
using this AI prompt The Prompt is quite
clear and precise about what I need help
with it mentions the kind of project I'm
working on which is an interactive
slideshow with do navigation and that
the slideshow should display images and
description for different projects it
also mentions the language types HTML
CSS and JavaScript followed by the
specific functionality that it requires
I've structured this prompt by splitting
it up into multiple smaller tasks with
both bullet points the bullet points in
the prompt help provide a clear
structure and make it easier for chat
GPT to understand our project needs and
hopefully generate code for each
requirement for example I'm asking it to
create a flexible HTML container for
each project slide and I want to start
by adding three projects to the slider
including images headings and
descriptions and the headings and
descriptions should be overlaid above
the images using a partially transparent
back ground and then I want to implement
a DOT navigation where each dot
represents a project and Visually
indicates the active slide users should
be able to switch between slides using
the dot navigation and I want a fade
transition between each slide and as
usual I'm asking for code comments and
explanations to understand the solution
better which as you've experienced with
other projects is a great learning
approach The Prompt seems to provide
enough information to build a solution
while the details of the images
descriptions or Aesthetics like color
scheme are not provided they aren't as
crucial to create a functional image
slideshow these can be easily customized
later all right so I'll copy this prompt
and paste it into chat gbt and let's see
what chat gbt has in store for us okay
we get back the HTML CSS and JavaScript
code for our image slideshow complete
with detailed comments explaining each
part's functionality so first I'll copy
the HTML code and paste it into
index.html then I'll copy the CSS and
paste all of it into styles.css
and copy the JavaScript code and paste
it into
script.js all right now let's review the
code in
index.html we have a div element with
the class slider and it wraps all the
individual slides which get creat
created with divs with the class slide
each slide div contains an image and
slide content displaying the project
name and description and it seems like
the sliders do navigation will be
dynamically generated using JavaScript
so there's a container element for the
navigation here at the bottom with the
class. navigation when I run the code it
looks like we need to update the paths
to the image files in our project
they're showing up as broken images so
why don't you take a moment to fix this
here's a challenge I want you to update
each image element to correctly point to
the image source and remember the images
are in this folder named images so pause
me now and give that a
go all right here we go now I'll update
the paths to point to the images stored
in my images folder here in an images
Source attribute I need to specify the
folder name which is images followed by
a forward slash before the image name so
for example this image element Source
points to the project 1. JPEG file now
I'll do the same for the other two
images all right let's test the
slideshow and good it seems like it's
working as expected so nice work if you
got that now we have a flexible HTML
container for each project slide with
responsive image resizing The Heading
and descriptions fully overlay the
images with a partially transparent
background and the dot navigation allows
us to switch between slides with a
smooth fade transition effect so not bad
at all on the first try but it looks
like we need to make a few adjustments
so let's walk through the rest of the
code and customize the slideshow to our
needs the CSS comments in styles.css
help explain what each CSS rule is doing
so for instance here it's resetting some
default Styles then we have this CSS for
the main slider container as well as all
the individual slides with the class
slide and it looks like this is setting
the opacity of an active slide to one so
that we can view it and it's styling the
image within each slide as well as the
content overlay and below are the styles
for the dot navigation all right so the
first thing I want to do is make sure
that the image inside each slide takes
up the full width and height of its
containing element because notice if I
shrink the browser window we see a gap
or some empty space between the image
and the dot navigation so let's fix this
I'll scroll down to where we're styling
the image within each slide right here
now the image is already set to take up
the full width of its containing element
here with width set to 100% so to set
the image inside each slide to also take
up the full height of its containing
element I'll update the height property
here to 100% so now if it's container
div with the class slide is resized the
image will resize along with it always
trying to fill the entire width and
height of the parent slide div so notice
that now we're not seeing that Gap below
the image but now it seems like the
aspect ratio of the image is a bit off
notice how it looks distorted here at
this width we can adjust that with a CSS
property called object fit this property
determines how the image should be
resized to fit its container and the
value cover ensures that the image will
scale up or down so that it covers the
entire area of its container without
stretching or distorting the image
notice how it crops the image in a way
that preserves its aspect ratio and
Central content so now it doesn't look
distorted Perfect all right so next I'd
like to pin the content area to the
bottom of the slide
that way it doesn't fully overlay the
image so here in the slide content rule
I'll change this top property set to
zero to bottom zero and then remove the
height set to 100% as well as this left
position property set to zero all right
that looks much better now we can see
more of our project images I also think
that the content background should be
slightly less transparent so here I see
where a semi-transparent background is
being set so I'll update this alpha or
transparency value here in the rgba
color function to 75% by sending it to
75 and that looks much better to
me now let's adjust the project name
with CSS we'll increase the font size
and add more visual space between the
project name and description so at the
top of styles.css I'll create a new rule
that Target gets the H2 element on the
page which remember is the project name
in each
slide and here I'll update the font size
using the CSS font size property and set
it to a larger value such as 26 pixels
and to create that extra space I'll use
a margin bottom property and set it to
12 pixels let's check it out and I think
that looks much better all right now
let's have a look at the JavaScript the
comments are super helpful full in
explaining each code block so here at
the top I see that it's getting the
required elements such as the slide
Dives and the dot navigation container
and this line of code initially sets the
first slide and Dot as active and then
we have the code to generate the dot
navigation based on the number of slides
so that's actually really cool because
as we add more and more of these Slide
divs the JavaScript is going to
dynamically generate more dots for the
navigation and it looks like this
function here handles navigating to a
specific Slide by first removing the
active class from all slides and dots
and then adding the active class to the
selected slide and Dot now everything in
the slideshow seems to be working great
but I think it would be really neat and
useful if the slideshow played
automatically so let's ask chat gbt to
implement an autoplay feature that
automatically switches to the next slide
every 5 Seconds I'll use this prompt
here which says says please update the
JavaScript code to automatically switch
to the next slide every 5 Seconds I'll
feed this prompt into chat
gbt and let's see okay we get back new
code for our Javascript file so what
I'll do is copy all of this code and
replace everything in script.js with the
updated code just to be sure that I
don't miss anything all right so let's
check it out it looks like we have two
new variables declared at the top
current slide which is an initialized to
zero and slide interval and now the
navigate to slide function automatically
Fades to the next slide every 5 Seconds
this JavaScript line here uses the set
interval function which is a built-in
method in JavaScript that's used to
execute a specific function or code
snipp it repeatedly at fixed time
intervals so in this case it calls the
next slide function to navigate to the
next slide every 500 m seconds which is
equivalent to 5 Seconds awesome then
here at the very bottom this line
initially autop plays the slideshow when
the page loads all right so let's test
it out I'll run my code and excellent
the slideshow plays by itself and then
every 5 Seconds it updates to show the
next slide perfect so fantastic you've
created an impressive image slideshow
you can use for your personal portfolio
website and remember it doesn't end here
I want you to customize iiz and enhance
a slideshow to suit your personal style
and project needs and make it truly your
own so I'm going to leave you with a
challenge here I want you to add more
projects custom images descriptions and
add links to your live projects I'll
kick off the first slide here in the
HTML by setting the project name to
website hero and updating the
description here in the paragraph
element and I want you to keep this
project handy because you're going to
use it later in a bigger project so stay
tuned and as always take a moment to ask
chat gbt to explain any of the code that
you don't quite understand or want to
learn more about great work let's move
on you are going to build your very own
personal homepage where you'll introduce
yourself to the world exhibit your
skills and display your projects imagine
a digital business card but more Dynamic
and personal and the best part is that
you will Implement and feature the
project slideshow you built earlier on
your homepage so let's get to it we'll
kick it off by discussing the project
with chat gbt and instructing it on our
intentions to ensure we're on the same
page then we'll follow it with a series
of prompts for each section of the page
this first prompt asks chat GPT for
guidance in building a personal homepage
using HTML and CSS it's a sort of broad
level brief to give chat GPT a sense of
the Project's nature and I also let it
know that I'll only request specific
code Snippets as we progress so there's
no need to provide code until I
explicitly ask for it and with this
prompt chubbt should be ready to start
so I'll copy and paste this prompt into
chat gbt and good it looks like chat gbt
is primed and ready to go so now let's
ask it to provide a basic HTML structure
with this prompt I'm giving chat gbt a
road map for our hom Pages layout and
overall the main building blocks of our
page I'm asking it to help me design a
basic struct structure for a personal
homepage and that it should have the
following sections a header a section
for display my projects an about section
and a section for displaying my skills
as well as a footer and I wanted to add
these sections as placeholders for now
as we'll be coding them and filling them
out step by step I'll feed this prompt
to chat gbt and let it do its thing I
get back some HTML so I'll copy this
code and paste it into
index.html and let's have a look it
looks like the HTML structure is a big
basic layout with placeholders for
different sections like the header
projects about skills and the footer
just as requested great so now let's
request the code for our page header in
navigation with this prompt I want chat
TBT to code an HTML header displaying my
name Gil H and navigation links for the
sections projects about and
skills and I get back new HTML where it
looks like the header section was
updated so I'll copy the header element
and replace the existing header element
with the new code I see that the main
heading or H1 was updated to display my
name and then we have a nav element
holding an unordered list which contains
all the page links as list items I'll
check out the latest code and see that
so far everything is looking great next
let's guide chat gbt to create the HTML
for our about section this section
should briefly in ruce who you are and
some of your achievements by linking to
a resume for example so I wanted to
guide me to create the HTML for the
about section it should include my
picture a friendly introduction and a
link to my resume so let's see what chat
gbt can do with this prompt in the
provided HTML code I do see that the
about section was updated with the
requested content fantastic I'll copy
this new section and replace the section
here in index.html with the new code
code the about content contains an image
element and it looks like I need to
update the source attribute here to
display my image which is located in the
images folder and it's named photo. jpeg
so here in the source attribute I'll
change the path to images SL photo. JPEG
and I'll update the alt attribute to
gills picture and in the paragraphs
below I see a friendly introduction
about me as well as the placeholder link
for for my resume which I'll leave as is
for now all right let's keep going by
asking chbt to develop the HTML for our
skill section this area is where we
might showcase our expertise and
proficiency levels in specific topics
for now we'll just list HTML CSS and
JavaScript but you can update it to
whatever you'd like the prompt says now
let's code the HTML for my skill section
and as mentioned we'll start with the
skills HTML CSS and JavaScript and each
skill should have a name and a
description and I also want to display a
progress bar representing my proficiency
in each skill so let's see what magic
chat gbt can cook up with this prompt
all right I get back some new HTML and
yes it looks like the skills section was
updated with the requested skills so
I'll copy just the skill section from
the new code then paste it in
index.html over the existing skill
section so in our skill section we have
the skills HTML CSS and JavaScript each
has a short description about each skill
as well as a progress bar to give us a
visual representation of each strength
and what's cool is that you'll be able
to adjust the percentages by updating
the width values in each of these style
attributes all right let's keep it going
by coding our footer the footer is going
to tie everything together and provide a
space for additional links with this
prompt I'm instructing chat gbt to
create the HTML for the page footer and
that it should contain copyright
information and links to my LinkedIn
Twitter and Instagram profiles and to
make the footer more interesting I want
to use icon fonts to display a social
media icon for each link I'll feed this
prompt to chat
gbt and let's see what we get good we
get the updated HTML for the page footer
and it looks like I first need to
include the icon font Library which in
this case is font awesome so I'll copy
this link element and add it to the head
section of my page just like that then
and I'll grab the new footer code and
add that to my page the footer contains
all the essential information I
requested providing links to LinkedIn
Twitter and Instagram and below the
copyright information let's have a look
at it in the browser and good we see the
icon fonts being displayed for each link
which makes it easier for visitors to
recognize the links I'll update this to
Gil H and moving on it's time to add
some style to our web page let's request
CSS from chat gbt using this prompt so I
wanted to design a simple modern CSS
layout for my homepage I want a
responsive layout that adjusts to
different screen sizes using CSS media
queries for the design I prefer a black
and white color scheme and sansera fonts
and I give it Specific Instructions to
make my picture smaller and rounded and
to add generous line height in visual
space around the content so that it
doesn't appear too cramped so I'll feed
this to chat gbt and see what it returns
all right I get back to New CSS so I'll
copy the code and paste it into
styles.css fingers crossed hopefully
this looks good all right and look how
our page has transformed not too bad it
provides a responsive design which
ensures a userfriendly experience
regardless of the device used and the
chosen color scheme and font give a
modern professional feel and the skill
section looks fantastic with the style
progress bars with our site content
elements in place our page is taking
shape so now let's spend some time
customizing the CSS so first I want to
increase the font size of the titles or
H2 elements for each of the sections and
Center them on the page so inst
styles.css I'll create a new rule that
targets all the H2 elements and here
I'll increase their font size to 30
pixels and align them center with text
align Center
and that's looking better now I want to
apply a generous margin between the
heading and the content below it I can
do that with the margin bottom property
and let's say 20 pixels okay that's
looking better the next thing I want to
do is add some space between the
paragraphs because notice how these two
paragraphs are looking pretty cramped
and I also want to open up the space
between the skills description and the
progress bar so back in the CSS I'll
select the paragraph graphs or P tags
and again with the margin bottom
property increase the margins to 16
pixels and that looks much better to me
looking through the CSS I see that the
about section has a padding value of 40
pixels and it seems like it doesn't need
to be that big so for now I'll just go
ahead and get rid of this padding
property and keeping with that change it
seems like the skill section also has a
padding value of 40 pixels which I don't
think we need for now so I'll also get
rid of this skills rule here but what I
can do now is create some more space
between each of the sections all at once
in one CSS rule remember the main
sections are contained within the
section
elements so I can Target the sections
with CSS and then set their top and
bottom margin value to 30 pixels and the
left and right margins to zero and that
applies consistent spacing across all
the sections looking good another change
I'll make in the header navigation is
style the hover state of the links to
give the user a visual indication that
the link is being hovered remember we
can do that using the hover pseudo class
as we've done in previous projects so
here in the CSS styles for the header
links I can follow a similar pattern
used here to style the navigation links
on Hover with nav Li a colon hover in
fact I can write it just like this
without the Li and it will do the same
thing when a user hovers over a link I
want to display an underline link so
I'll set the text decoration to
underline and there we go our hover
state is all set all right now comes
your big challenge for this project and
that is implementing the project
slideshow after you built the slideshow
project I mentioned to keep your project
slideshow handy because you were going
to use it on a larger project and now is
that time I want you to add add your
project slideshow to the homepage first
you'll place the slideshows HTML here in
the project section then add the
slideshow CSS to the file slideshow. CSS
and paste the JavaScript into
script.js I've also included some images
you can use here in the images folder
but customize the code as needed to fit
your slideshow so take your time with
this and I'll catch you in the next
scrim to go over it together you've got
this
all right this was a pretty big
challenge so hopefully you were able to
implement the project slideshow in your
web page I'll bring in my project
slideshow by first pasting the HTML to
my slideshow here in the project section
I'll replace this placeholder with my
code notice how I've included the div
with a class slider as well as the dot
navigation next I'll paste my slideshow
CSS in slideshow. CSS and bring all of
my slideshows JavaScript into
script.js hopefully you realize that you
need to link your index.html file to
slideshow. CSS so let's do that I'll
copy one of these link elements in the
head section of my page and update it so
that it points to the file slideshow.
CSS now we don't see our slideshow yet
and that's because we need to point to
script.js here at the bottom of our HTML
file so just about the closing body tag
I'll add script
tags with a source attribute that points
to the file
script.js all right and now the
slideshow is displaying on the web page
perfect if you got this far into the
challenge
outstanding now let's spend a little
time customizing the slideshows HTML and
CSS so that it fits our web page
better notice how the project titles are
currently using H2 tags but looking at
the site structure it appears that they
would work better as third level or H3
headings this would improve the overall
hierarchy and accessibility of the page
so we'll switch the H2 tags to H3
tags this small change does make a
difference in our content structure
let's have a look at the slideshow CSS
at the top it's using the universal
selector or the asterisk and CSS which
targets every element on the web page
and it's setting its margin and padding
to zero I don't think we need that in
this file since styles.css is already
handling some of this for us so I'll
remove the margin and padding properties
from this rule but I'll keep box sizing
border box because the Box sizing
property controls how the width and
height of elements get calculated you
see by default any extra padding or
borders you add to an element will make
it wider or taller than you might expect
and it can throw off your layout so with
box sizing set to border box any padding
or border given to an element
automatically gets included in the
elements dimensions and it likely won't
cause any strange or quirky behavior in
your layouts so I'll keep this in now
how about we round the borders of the
slider using the Border radius property
here in the slider rule 8 pixels sounds
good to me we don't quite see the Border
radius yet but we'll make some
adjustments later which will make the
slideshow appear much better on our page
and now that we've updated our project
titles to H3 elements let's style those
here and slide show. CSS now we could
Target all the H3 elements like this but
since this CSS is specific to the slider
we don't want it to override any
potential Styles we write for the H3 in
the styles.css file so what we can do is
Select only the H3 elements that are in
the div with the class slider with do
slider a space followed by the H3
selector and let's increase the font
size of the project titles in the slider
to 24 pixels I am noticing a bit of an
extra Gap below the slideshow
description displayed by the paragraph
It's a bit nitpicky but we could remove
the space by setting the margin of the P
tag and the slider class to zero so I'll
say slider P margin
zero and good the space is gone and I
like how that looks all right we are
almost to the finish line now let's add
what are referred to as containers to
our site for better content structure
containers will help give our sections a
more uniform and censured look across
different devices containers are also
common across all Web projects for
various reasons we'll use them to
control the layout of content on the
page particularly control the width
alignment and positioning of our
sections because notice how they're
currently looking too wide stretching
from one edge of the browser to the
other so we can control the widths and
improve the overall design of the page
with containers and I'll have you
implement the container ERS with a
challenge which I'll paste here in
prompts MD you'll interact with cat gbt
by asking it to provide the code for
creating containers for your site's
content and I'll give you this prompt to
help kick things off so what you'll need
to do is head over to chat gbt and open
a new chat then provide it with this
prompt now chat GPT doesn't really need
to know the full context of your project
this HTML code snippet should be enough
to give it the necessary information to
provide you an example and CS says code
snippet for adding containers around
your project so you'll need to add the
suggested CSS to the project and then
update the HTML structure with
containers for the projects about and
skill sections only so go ahead and
pause me now ask chbt and then add the
new HTML and CSS to the
project all right hopefully that went
well now let's go over adding containers
to the site together I'll start by
copying this prompt and pasting it into
chat gvt
you may have gotten a different output
but I see that I can create a container
by defining the container class in my
CSS and applying it to the appropriate
section of my HTML code first I'll copy
this container snippet and paste it into
styles.css
then it looks like I need to add the
container class in the div with a class
about content so I'll scroll down to my
about section and here in the class
attribute add the class container and
make sure that both classes are
separated by a space just like that
looking at the container class the max
width property applies a maximum width
to the container and margin zero Auto
Center aligns the container horizontally
and then we're adding some padding for
spacing I think a max withth value of
1200 pixels is too wide so I'll set it
to a smaller value like 750 pixels and
since we're applying 30 pixels of top
and bottom margins to each section we
don't need to add padding for spacing
it's it's all being taken care of I'll
check out the about section in the
browser and notice that when I expand
the browser the content does not get any
wider than 750 pixels and I usually like
to give containers a fluid width using a
percentage value and this will really
help with narrow screen sizes and small
devices so now the container should keep
the content at 90% the width of its
parent and I like how that looks so
let's move on and add containers to the
skill section and our slideshow so first
in the slider section we can do
something similar here in this class
attribute by including the container
class and good notice how our slider is
no longer taking up the full width of
the page it now has width const
strengths so it doesn't get any wider
than 750 pixels but then it adjusts as
needed when the browser resizes to a
narrower size perfect finally let's take
care of the the skill section for this
we'll do something slightly different
currently within the skill section
there's no element that wraps all of the
skills content so we'll need to create
that with a div so inside the section at
a div and give it the class container
just like the other elements and this
container div is going to wrap all of
the skills content so just above the
closing section tag I'll add a closing
div tag then make sure to indent the
content inside it and good wrapping the
skills content within a container
ensures that the content is horizontally
centered and now it's consistent with
all the other
sections if you were able to add the
containers to the web page and make it
look similar to this fantastic job so
finally now that we have all of our
containers in place we can make the page
more visually interesting for example
let's make the about section Stand Out
On the Page by applying a background
color that stretches from one side of
the browser to the other we'll do that
in styles.css
here in the about rule first I'll open
up the space in the about element by
applying 20 pixels of top and bottom
padding and then we'll give it a
background color using the background
color property we'll set the background
color to light gray using the value
pound eded D Ed D and great that's
exactly what I wanted notice how it adds
a nice visual touch to the page and
helps break up the
content and it looks like I have some
extra unnecessary CSS for the about
section down here in the media query so
I can delete this entire CSS rule since
we're handling the padding for it and
the base
Styles all right fantastic our personal
homepage is now complete it's quite
amazing to see how working with an AI
tool like chat gbt can turn a concept
into a functioning web page now as a
final challenge for you I want you to
make this web page yours for example
update the content and images and add a
custom color scheme remember this is
your personal web page so spend some
time customizing it so that it reflects
more of who you are and be sure to share
your solution with the scrimba community
in fact you can click on this image
right here to head over to the today I
did Discord Channel and share the link
to your web page so again outstanding
job and I'll see you back soon to build
more cool
projects we are taking a significant
step forward by introducing you to get
Hub where coders and Builders store and
share their projects GitHub is like a
library but for code that can be either
public or private it serves as a
platform for what we call Version
Control allowing you to save your work
at different stages and even roll back
to a previous stage if needed and the
best part is that it lets developers
work together on the same project so
whether you're working alone or as a
team GitHub will be part of your
building workflow we are going to take
the personal homepage project you've
built and put it up on GitHub setting up
a GitHub account is pretty
straightforward if you haven't already
go to github.com or click right on this
image to go there click the sign up
button in the top right then enter your
details and create a username for your
account once you verify your email
address you're all set all right so
first to transfer your project from a
scrim to a GitHub repository you'll need
to download the code from the scrim onto
your computer similar to how you did in
the previous section of this course
click on the gear icon in the bottom
right corner of your scram then click
download as zip and that's going to
download a zip file to your computer
unzip the file and you'll see your
project files inside a folder now in the
folder you might see some new unfamiliar
files like package.json and another
named V config.js go ahead and delete
those files because you're not going to
need them and I also suggest renaming
your project folder to help you keep
track of it and now you're ready to
upload your project to GitHub the GitHub
interface is quite userfriendly with
your repositories easily accessible from
the homepage so now let's create a
GitHub repository often referred to as a
repo a repo is like a project folder
where all the files related to a
particular project are stored to create
a new repository click on the new button
in the top right give your new repo a
name like personal homepage then give it
an optional description it's up to you
whether to make it public or private and
when you download a scrim it includes a
readme file so in this case I won't
initialize the repository with a readme
file a readme.md file provides essential
information about your project it
typically includes a brief description
of the project and instructions on how
to use or contribute to it so I'll leave
this unchecked then click create
repository to finalize my settings after
creating your new repository GitHub
takes you to its quick setup page
providing you instructions for adding
files to your repository using various
methods the drag and drop feature is
best suited for those just getting
started with GitHub and for small
projects like this one so that's what
we'll use click the link for uploading
an existing file then open the folder on
your computer that contains your project
files select all the files you want to
upload to your repository then drag
those files and drop them onto the
designated area that says drag files
here to add them to your repository once
the files are added you'll see a preview
of the new files below okay after upload
loing your file scroll down to the
commit changes section here you can
optionally add a brief description of
the changes you made for example initial
commit then click commit changes and
this will commit the files to the
repository on What's called the main
branch and from here you might update
your readme file for example by clicking
this edit icon then you can set the main
heading to my personal homepage with a
short description below and remove
certain parts not specific to this
project and then commit the latest
changes to the to the readme file and
then from here if you make changes to
your project and want to update the
version on GitHub to ensure your repo is
updated with the most recent version of
your project simply click on the repo's
add files button and choose upload files
and just like earlier you can drag and
drop the updated files here and GitHub
will recognize these as changes to
existing files and update them
accordingly and there you have it your
files up on GitHub now keep in mind that
what we've just gone through is the
simplest way to use GitHub in real world
projects developers often use git a
command line tool for more granular
control over versioning and
collaboration but you don't need to
really worry about that right now
however there are various courses and
lessons on scrimba that you can review
to learn more about working with GitHub
for example this section here on setting
up a local Dev environment and working
with GitHub is a good place to start
click on this image if you're curious
about it and want to learn more but for
now congrats you've successfully pushed
your first project to
GitHub we're going to blend technology
and lifestyle to build a Smart Home
Mobile interface that allows users to
control various aspects of their smart
home such as lighting temperature and
even their favorite tunes and we'll do
our best to give it a sleek and modern
aesthetic touch and naturally chubbt
will help us throughout this journey so
let's Jump Right In this time we'll use
several prompts to describe specific
elements and functionalities we want in
our interface instead of overwhelming
chat GPT with a single complex request
we'll ask it to help us incrementally
hopefully that will make problem solving
easier by breaking down complex tasks
into manageable chunks and as Builders
this approach allows us to clarify
iterate and get more precise responses
with each step so I'll kick things off
with this prompt I'm letting chat gbt
know that it's building a Smart Home
Mobile interface using HTML CSS and
JavaScript and that the interface should
allow users to control various aspects
of their smart home such as lighting
temperature and music preferences to
start I only wanted to create the HTML
structure for the smart home interface
I'd like it to include a header with the
title and three main sections for
lighting temperature and music and that
each section should include buttons to
control lighting temperature and music
based on user preferences so let's see
how chat gbt tackles this
task all right it looks like chat gbt
has given us some pretty fantastic HTML
to work with now I'll start implementing
the provided code by copying this code
and pasting it into
index.html in the HTML there's a header
element containing the title and below a
main element which holds three sections
one for the lighting control another for
the temperature control and a third
section for the music Control good next
to enhance the interface design and make
it more in intive I want to use icon
fonts to display light temperature and
music icons next to each section heading
and for the corresponding buttons I'll
ask chat GPT to provide those using this
prompt I'm saying hey chat GPT use icon
fonts to display light temperature and
music icons next to each section heading
and for the corresponding buttons so
I'll feed this prompt to chat gbt and
let's see what we get it looks like it
first provides a link to the font
awesome Library so I'll copy it then
paste it in the head section of
index.html right here and then below it
says that I need to modify the section
headings and the buttons in the main
section to include the icons so I'll
copy this entire main snippet then
replace my main element with the new
code okay let's have a look and great
now we see the icons display next to
each heading as well as in the button
controls now I think it's it's best to
remove any unnecessary or redundant text
in the user interface for example the
word control in lighting control as well
as the temperature and music Control
sections also the word temperature in
the increase and decrease buttons and
I'll update the music control buttons to
display only the text play pause and
next and overall I think this looks much
cleaner oh okay with the HTML and icon
fonts in place let's apply CSS styles to
the page with this third prompt I'll ask
chat gbt to apply CSS styles to achieve
a mobile friendly layout with a dark and
Sleek design and then to use soft
gradients shadows and the provided
colors here for the backgrounds buttons
and other elements hopefully chubbt can
create an aesthetically pleasing design
with the colors I provided so I'll feed
this prompt to chachu BT and I get back
the Cs CSS which I'll copy and paste
into styles.css
awesome I think chat GPT did a pretty
good job on the first try so it seems
like the smart home interface is really
starting to take shape but there are a
few minor adjustments we can make to
improve the layout and I want you to
work on those with a CSS
challenge I'd like you to work on UI
adjustments by first center aligning the
content inside each section and adding
more space around the content so that it
looks more like this I'd also like you
to adjust the space between the buttons
notice how there's no space between the
buttons when they each appear on their
own line so you'll need to fix this in
the challenge so pause me now work
through these steps and I'll catch you
soon to go over it
together all right hopefully that wasn't
too bad first I'll Center align the
content inside each section using the
text align property here and the section
Rule and setting it to the Value Center
and to add more spacing around the
content in each section I'll increase
the padding value currently it's 15
pixels but I'll set it to a larger value
such as 20 pixels next to adjust the
space between the buttons I'll update
the margin property here in the button
rule currently there's only a 10 pixel
margin applied to the right side of each
button but I like to apply margin on all
four sides of the button to prevent them
from looking like this when each button
is on its own line so what I'll do is
replace margin right with the margin
shorthand then apply a five pixel margin
to all four sides of the button and that
creates the spacing I'm looking for
between the buttons much better now this
media query at the bottom applies styles
to the main section and button elements
only when the browser or device is 600
pixels or narrower I'll keep the main
rule here but I'm good with the base
padding of 20 pixels applied to each
section and the base margins we just set
to space out the buttons so I'll remove
these two CSS rules from the media query
if you got the control sections in your
interface to look close to this nice
work next up I'd like to enhance the
lighting control by implementing a
toggle switch instead of a button this
will give our interface a more seamless
and intuitive control mechanism so I'll
use this fourth prompt to ask chat GPT
to update the HTML and CSS to implement
a toggle switch for the lighting control
instead of a button and I want it to
keep the switch color consistent with
the rest of the interface so I'll pass
the prompt on to chat GPT and I see it
suggest that I replace the lighting
control button with this label element
so I'll copy this snippet and make the
changes in my my lighting control
section in this case this label element
is being used to create a custom toggle
switch using a checkbox an input element
with a type of checkbox means it will
display as a checkbox as you can see
here in the lighting control section
with the provided CSS we can make the
checkbox and this span element with the
class slider look like a toggle switch
so here we have new CSS that selects the
class switch as well as the input
element and the span with the class
slider so I'll copy this code snippet
and add it to styles.css just above the
media
query all right perfect this creates the
desired appearance of a toggle switch
and notice how the toggle animation
smoothly transitions the background and
the position of the toggle Circle I see
that's being done with this CSS here
which apply CSS to the toggle switch
slider only when a user clicks on it or
when the checkbox is in a checked state
it updates the background color and
transforms its position using this
special CSS translate X function this is
what actually makes it move 26 pixels on
the xais or from left to right so as you
can see CSS is pretty awesome to be able
to create effects like this right in
your browser now it does look like we
need to make the toggle switch wider for
users here in the switch class I see
that the width is currently set to 60
pixels so let's try making it twice as
wide by updating the width value to 120
pixels and that looks really good now we
need to adjust the position of the
slider Circle when toggled on again
that's being controlled here with the
translate function it's set to 26 pixels
so let's try doubling the value to 52
pixels and that doesn't quite work we
need to increase it by a little bit more
more let's say 70 pixels we're almost
there I'll try the value 85 pixels and
yes that looks
perfect all right so when the lights are
toggled on the toggle switch's
background should match the bright pink
background of the buttons when hovered
to better indicate an on state that's a
quick
change what I'll do is swap the
background color of this slider class
with the background color of the input
or toggle switch when it's checked so
I'll just cut this background color
property out of this rule then paste it
in the slider Rule and bring the initial
background color property down to the
input checked Rule and that should do it
okay so when the lights are off the
background color of the toggle switch
matches the purple of the buttons and
then when we turn the lights on it
switches to the bright pink perfect next
up I'd like to enhance the interactivity
by adding a subtle glow effect behind a
pressed or clicked button to provide
visual feedback to the user I'm not
feeling the bright orange background
color that's applied to a button when
clicked and I want you to work on that
with this
challenge you going to write your very
own short prompt for chat gbt to provide
the CSS for adding a soft glow effect
behind a pressed or clicked button in
the prompt I also recommend providing
chat gbt with the CSS for your buttons
so that it can more closely match its
Aesthetics so pause me now write your
prompt here and I'll meet you back soon
to go over it
together hey how it go hopefully you
were able to write a prompt that
successfully created the glow effect for
pressed or clicked buttons I'll add my
prompt here which says add a soft glow
effect behind a pressed or clicked
button remember I suggested providing
chat gbt with the CSS for your buttons
so I'll say here is the CSS for my
button
then paste the base styles for the
button as well as the hover State Styles
and I'll follow this up by saying that
the glow should match the bright pink
background of a hovered button chat gbt
is pretty smart so it should be able to
figure it out I'll copy and paste this
into chat GPT and let's see it says that
to add a soft glow effect behind a
pressed or clicked button I can modify
the CSS as follows it seems like the
only thing I need to do is copy this box
shadow property and add it to my button
active CSS
rule I'll test it out by clicking one of
the buttons such as increase and cool I
do see a soft pink glow behind the
button although I'd like to make it
stand out more so I'll adjust this Alpha
transparency value to 80% by switching
it
to8 and that does look a little bit
better now I do want to remove this
orange background color when a button is
clicked or pressed PR which is called
the active state so I can do that by
removing this background color property
also to remove the default browser
outline for a button in its active State
we can use the outline property and set
it to the value none now keep in mind
that when removing the default outline
for active buttons you should ensure
there's some other clear visual
indication when the button is clicked
especially for accessibility reasons now
we've added the background glow effect
so I think it's safe to remove it and
perfect the soft glow behind the buttons
when clicked adds a nice visual touch to
the
interface next let's tackle temperature
control here in the temperature section
we'll update the code to display the
temperature above the buttons initially
at a comfortable 78° Fahrenheit allowing
users to increase or decrease it by
clicking the corresponding buttons this
time I'll say hey chat PT please update
the necessary code to to display the
temperature at 78° F initially and to
allow users to increase or decrease the
temperature by clicking the
corresponding buttons and I want it to
style the temperature display
accordingly with CSS so here you go chat
GPT do your thing so I get back some
HTML for updating the temperature
control section it looks like I need to
add this div with the class temperature
display so I'll copy that and paste it
just above my temperature control
buttons I'll copy the CSS code to style
the temperature
display and add it to
style.css and we get the JavaScript for
the temperature control functionality
I'll copy the code and paste it in
script.js so here it's getting the
temperature display element then setting
the initial temperature value to 78 as
requested it looks like this function
updates the temperature display and this
event handler increases the temperature
when the increase button is clicked and
this one decreases is the temperature
value when the decrease button is
clicked and then it's calling the update
temperature display function here to
initialize the temperature display on
the page Let's test it out all right
there's our temperature initially set to
78° fahr I'll click increase and good
each time I click it the temperature
increases by one and when I click
decrease the temperature decreases by
one the only thing I want to do is
adjust the spacing around the
temperature display and I can do that
with margins here in the temperature
display rule I see that there's only a
top margin of 10 pixels but I can update
this by changing it to margin 10 pixels
top and bottom and then zero pixels left
and right and that should do it yep
finally let's work on the music Control
section by implementing the play pause
stop and next button functionality now
we're not going to actually play music
but we can simulate play music by
displaying a random song name when the
play button is clicked then clearing the
song name when a stop button is clicked
and clicking the next button will change
the song to another random song as usual
I'll ask chat GPT to provide the code
for me with this prompt I'm asking it to
update the code to implement the music
Control section with play pause stop and
next button functionality it should
display a random funny song name when
the play button is clicked and to make
sure that the song changes when a user
clicks the next button and it should
Style the song text with CSS I'll copy
and paste this into TBT and I get back
the updated HTML code for the music
Control section it looks like I need to
add this div with a class song name then
replace the play button and the stop
button so I'll just go ahead and copy
these elements here and make the
necessary updates in the music Control
section there we go I see the song name
and then the play stop and next buttons
now for the CSS I'll copy this new CSS
code to style the div with a class song
name and paste it in into
style.css the text is slightly larger
but it looks like I need to add similar
spacing around the song text so just
like with the temperature display I'll
change margin top to margin 10 pixels
top and bottom 0er pixels left and right
all right that looks good and now the
JavaScript I have new JavaScript code to
handle the music control and random song
names so I'll copy this JavaScript
snippet and add it to script.js at the
very top let's say below the temperature
variable this line gets the song name
display element and here we have our
list of funny song names stored as
string inside the funny song names array
we have an is playing variable
initialized to false and looks like it's
tracking the current song index which is
set to zero initially and this event
listener here handles the play pause
button when clicked if it's clicked
while the song is playing it changes the
play button to display pause otherwise
it it changes the button to display play
this event listener handles the stop
button and then this one handles the
next button by displaying a random song
name and it seems like this function
here is what's used to get a random song
name all right let's test it out in the
music Control section I'll click the
play button and I see that the button
text and icon switches to pause and I
see a random song name Funky Chicken
Dance nice when I click the stop button
the song resets and the pause button
switches back to play and clicking play
displays another random song name and
then clicking the next button switches
the song names so it looks like the
JavaScript functionality works perfectly
so there isn't much work or
customization left for us except for
giving our smart home app a cooler name
of course I'm not quite feeling the name
smart home control in fact I'll even ask
chat GPT for some name suggestions using
this prompt help me name this smart home
interface project Pro by suggesting
clever product names so let's see what
names we get
back all right here I see names such as
home Harmony domach Eco EAS Casa
conductor and a few others out of these
I'm liking the name home Harmony so I'll
choose that one I'll update the title
here to home
Harmony and there we have it all right
so that wraps up building our Smart Home
Mobile interface with the help of chaty
BT and as us ual I want you to customize
this project and make it truly your own
experiment with different colors and add
additional features or sections like
security water sprinkling or Appliance
controls for example you can use the
existing code and chat gbt to help guide
you through it you might even try to
rebuild the smart home interface all on
your own using similar props and be sure
to share your solution in the scrimba
discords today I did channel so be super
proud of all you've built so far and
let's keep moving
we are taking our Smart Home Mobile
interface project to the next level by
learning how to transform it into a
truly mobile friendly app that users can
install on their devices and
conveniently launch from their home
screen there are various ways we can
achieve this but as usual I'll turn to
chat GPT for some guidance on how to do
this using this prompt I'm asking it to
guide me through the necessary steps to
make the smart home interface more
mobile friendly by allowing users to add
it to their devic's home screen for easy
access I'm just picking up where the
chat left off during the development of
the smart home interface project so I'll
paste The Prompt here and let's see what
chat gbt suggests it looks like chat gbt
provided some insightful instructions it
says that we can achieve this by
creating what's called a progressive web
app or pwa in short a progressive web
app is a web application that can
deliver an applike experience to users
by adding or installing it on the user's
device without needing to go through an
app store we're going to create a simple
version of a progressive web app then
below is a step-by-step guide on how to
make the smart home interface mobile
friendly and installable the first step
is to ensure mobile responsiveness we
built our interface to adapt and look
good on various screen sizes and
orientations in fact this metatag
included in the head of the page make
sure that the layout scales to fit the
size of the device it's viewed on so
we're all set there then it mentions
that we need to add something called a
web app manifest that sounds intense the
purpose of this file is to include
essential information about the app and
how it should appear and work on a
user's device and chat GPT gives us all
the code we need to create it so I'll
create a new file in my project and name
it manifest.json
then copy the provided code and paste it
in my new file this code you see here is
called Json which stands for JavaScript
object notation and you might realize
that it's very similar to JavaScript
objects in terms of structure and syntax
both Json and JavaScript objects share
similar key value pair structures this
Json code holds various properties to
Define essential details like the app's
name the start URL where it should open
the display mode to determine how it
appears on the device and the icons to
display on the home screen so first I'll
update the name and short name values to
the name of my app which is called home
Harmony now when a user decides to add
your app to their home screen the device
needs an icon to represent your app so
the icons array lists the images that
will appear on the home screen help
users recognize our app at a glance and
you'll often have a list of various icon
sizes and formats ensuring the icon
looks crisp and clear on different
devices in this case we only have two
listed one icon is one 92x 192 pixels
which is a common size for many Android
devices and the other is 512x 512 pixels
which can be used for larger displays or
higher resolution screens you don't need
to worry about creating the icons
because I've provided the two icons as
PNG files in the icons folder this is
what the home screen icon looks like I
used a design tool called figma to
create it if you're curious so now I
just need to update the source values to
point to my images I'll update the first
one to icons SL ion-1 192x 192 and the
Second Source to icons for/
i-512 by 512 in the web app manifest
file the start URL property specifies
the URL where the app should start or
open I'll set the value to a forward
slash which typically represents the
root or homepage of the app and the
display property determines how the app
should be displayed on a user's device
setting the value to Standalone makes it
appear and function like a standalone
app without the browser's typical UI
elements like the address bar or UI
buttons which provides a more immersive
and app-like experience the background
color property defines a placeholder
background color for the app to display
immediately before the stylesheet loads
in this case it's already set to the
same dark purple color as the body
background good now the theme color
property sets the default theme color
for various UI elements in the app like
the title bar or
toolbar let's set it to the lighter
shade of purple used in the background
gradients for each
section and that should be it for the
Manifest this file plays a significant
role in giving our app the mobile app
capabilities you can think of it as a
blueprint that tells the device how our
mobile app should behave and appear and
chbt reminds us that we need to link our
HTML file to the Manifest using this
link tag so I'll copy it and paste it
inside the head element this is what
will let the browser know that the web
app can be installed and displayed like
a mobile app chat GPT also suggests some
optional steps that we're not going to
worry about for this project but you
should test your app on various mobile
devices and browsers to ensure that it
looks and behaves as expected all right
so here comes the part we've been
waiting for to install the app on your
device and launch it from a user's home
screen you'll first need to deploy it or
put it live on the web using a tool like
netlify just like you learned in the
previous section of this course if you
need a refresher on how to do that click
on this image to review the scrim on
deploying and sharing your projects once
your project is live on the web visit
the live link on your phone or tablet
for example most mobile browsers offer a
manual way to add your web application
to the devic's home screen for example
in Safari on iOS you add your web app to
your home screen by tapping the share
button at the bottom of the browser
browser then select add to home screen
here you can see the home screen icon
and you're able to customize the name if
desired then tap add and that should add
the app's name and icon to your home
screen and clicking on the icon launches
the app notice the purple colored
toolbar at the top which we set with the
theme color property here in the
Manifest file and now you can start
interacting with the smart home
interface on your
device so congrats this was a huge step
in your building Journey you've
successfully transformed your web app
into a mobile app experience so give
yourself a round of applause and be sure
to share the link to your deployed
project with friends and colleagues to
show off what you've
built this is a big step because now you
are going to build a Chrome extension
what is that well a Chrome extension is
a small piece of software that enhances
the browsing experience within the
Chrome browser it often helps users be
more efficient by tailoring Chrome's
function fun ality towards individual
needs and preferences these extensions
range from simple tools like ad blockers
note taking and password managers to
more complex applications such as
productivity boosters and project
management if you visit the Chrome web
store you can check out all the
different types of Chrome extensions now
building a Chrome extension might sound
a little intimidating but worry not
we're going to demystify the process
together step by step with chubbt before
we dive in let's review what we're
building snap stash is a shopping wish
list Chrome extension
this extension will let users save the
URL of their current browser tab to a
shopping wish list the shopping list
will display the saved items according
to various categories such as pets books
electronics and more and the best part
is that the saved items persist even
after closing or refreshing the browser
and we'll use HTML CSS and JavaScript to
build it once again we're building our
extension incrementally by breaking down
our tasks into several AI prompts and
here is our first prompt it's designed
to give chat gbt an overview of what
we're trying to build a shopping list
Chrome extension that uses HTML CSS and
JavaScript that should let users save
the URL of the current browser Tab and
when a user opens the Chrome extension
on a page with an item they like they
should be able to select a category and
then click a save button to add the tabs
URL to a list displayed below and the
list should display each item's link
next to the selected category in this
case the categories to select should be
books clothes shoes Electronics pets and
health so first I wanted to suggest a
stepbystep guide to help me get started
so let's see what chbt can do with this
prompt okay it instructs us to create
various files manifest.json pop up. HTML
popup.js and
popup.js
manifest.json is at the heart of all
Chrome extensions it defines the
important properties of your extension
just like the Manifest file we work with
to turn web apps into Mobile friendly
apps so first I'll set the name property
to the extensions name snap stash now in
this manifest we have properties
different from those we worked with on a
previous project for example we have a
property for requesting and setting
permissions in this case the extension
will have permission to interact with
the currently active browser Tab and the
actions property sets certain browser
actions like the default file to load
and pop up when the user clicks to
launch the extension in this case it's
pop up. HTML it also sets the default
icon that should appear in the Chrome
toolbar it looks like we have three icon
sizes listed here now for this project
I'll only use the largest icon which is
128x 128 so I'll delete the other two
and I've already included the icon here
in the images folder this is what it
should look like chat GPT gives us the
basic setup here for Popup HTML so I'll
copy the code and replace everything in
my HTML with the new code the HTML
defines the heading category selection
the save button and the item list I'll
make a quick change by updating the
heading to the extension name snap stash
and I'd also like to make a change to
the select element displaying all the
categories as option elements instead of
displaying the text select a category
here as a label I'd like this text to
display by default as the first option
of the select menu so how about you work
on that so pause me now and take a
moment to set the default select option
to select a
category all right hopefully you got
that what I'll do is remove this label
element entirely then inside the select
element at the very top I'll add an
option
element I'll set its value attribute to
an empty set of quotes and within that
the text select a category and you'll
often see these default options
displayed with two dashes before and
after the text like that so if you were
able to create this option nice work in
the mini browser we can see a preview of
what it's looking like so far and next
we'll apply some initial styles to the
popup using this CSS I'll copy the CSS
code and paste it into pop up. CSS now
while I'm here I'll quickly update the
CSS by making the body of the popup SL
slly wider I'll change the width value
to 300
pixels finally let's add the JavaScript
to popup.js
so this JavaScript contains event
listeners and actions that are typically
used in the context of Chrome browser
extensions this event listener ensures
that the JavaScript will not run until
the HTML is fully loaded then it's
getting the three elements from pop up.
HTML and assigning them to variables and
with this code when the user selects a
category for the item and and clicks the
save button it first gets the selected
category like books clothes and shoes
and then this code here chrome. tabs.
query is a special method provided by
Chrome that's specific to Chrome
extensions it's what lets you manipulate
and interact with the currently active
tab in the browser in this case it
creates the HTML list item with the link
and text to display in the item list all
right so it looks like we have all the
main components of our extension in
place the next step is to load the EXT
ition in Chrome and test it first you'll
need to make sure that you download the
code from your scram onto your computer
exactly as you've done in previous
projects after that open your Chrome
browser and go to the URL
chrome/ extensions it should look like
this and once you're there be sure to
enable developer mode by toggling the
switch at the top right corner then
click the load unpack button and select
the folder on your computer containing
the project files and make sure that the
extension itself is enabled now now in
your Chrome toolbar click the extensions
icon in the top right and you should see
your new extension icon in the list
there it is snap stash click on it and
the popup should appear from here you
can visit a page with an item you like
or wish to purchase select a category
click save item and a link with the
selected category will be added to the
list and it looks like that worked
awesome so it looks like this is a
pretty solid foundation to build from
and there are many improvements and
enhancements we can make like displaying
the items name instead of only the
category also saving items permanently
and removing items we'll do just that
and more when we continue working on the
Chrome extension in the next
Grim okay we have our Chrome extensions
basic structure and styles in place and
tested that it works now let's build the
rest of the extension first up I don't
like how users only see the category
name when they save an item to the list
so let's update the extension by not
only displaying the item name and
category but also showing a preview of
the item name before users select a
category and save it and I want the
content in the item list to persist even
after the user refreshes or closes their
browser that way they never lose their
shopping list with each prompt we can
essentially add a new layer to our
Chrome extension so here in our second
prompt we're letting C GPT know that the
user should see a preview of the item
name before selecting a category and
saving it and that both the preview text
item link should display an item's Name
by accessing the current tab's title
element which on most shopping sites is
the name of the product that title text
is often quite long so I want to
truncate the item name to 50 characters
Max and the saved items should display
after closing or refreshing the browser
this might involve permission updates in
the Manifest so I'm instructing chat gbt
to update the Manifest file as needed
and as always add detailed comments
explaining the JavaScript let's try this
prompt out
chat TBT says that I need to update the
Manifest file to include new permissions
and a background script to store and
manage the saved items so I'll update
the permissions property in my manifest
and add the new background property the
new storage permission grants the
extension access to Chrome special
service for storing and retrieving data
like our shopping list and this new
background property sets up a helpful
script called a service worker which
runs in the background and can do a lot
of smart stuff like listen for various
browser events and even handle tasks
like permanently saving our items in the
browser storage so the user never loses
them in fact chat gbt even provides the
code to this new background.js file so
I'll need to create a new file in my
project named
background.js and paste this new code
into
it so this is the short script that's
going to manage the storage of Saved
items background.js will run in the
background independently of the pages
you're viewing and its purpose is to
remember the items in the shopping list
even when the browser is closed or if
multiple windows of the extension are
opened all right next to preview the
shopping items we need to update
popup.js
Title and it looks like we need to make
a pretty big update to the JavaScript
logic in popup.js so I'll copy the code
and replace everything that's currently
in popup.js with the new
code so this block of code is what
updates the item preview based on the
current tab's Title by accessing the
Page's title and this is where the text
length is being truncated to 50
characters then the item preview text is
being set here and it looks like the
save button functionality was updated to
save the selected item to storage
chrome. storage. sync. getet and chrom
storage. sync. set are special methods
provided by Chrome to access its service
for storing and retrieving data so here
it's saving the item to storage and here
it's upd dating the shopping list with
the truncated item name then this block
of code loads and displays all saved
items from chrome
storage all right good so it looks like
the JavaScript is going to provide the
functionality we need now from our
initial test earlier it looks like the
extension is not displaying the proper
icon on the extensions page so I want
you to troubleshoot this with the help
of chat
gbt so pause me and take a moment to
interact with chubbt and ask it to help
you display a 128x 128 icon for your
Chrome extension on the extensions
page all right hopefully chbt was able
to help you out I'll just let cat TBT
know that I built a Chrome extension and
that it's not displaying the 128 x18
icon I created for it on the extensions
page and it says that I need to check my
manifest file and ensure that I've
correctly specify the path to the 128x
128 icon using this icons property okay
I don't see that property in my manifest
so let me add
it I'll include it just below the action
property okay it looks like we're ready
to test the latest changes now we can't
run and test our updates here in the
scrim so make sure the project folder on
your computer has all the latest updates
then head back over to the Chrome
extensions URL and click the refresh or
reload button here in the extension and
that will load all the latest file
updates for the extension I immediately
see the extensions icon that's a great
sign and if I visit a products page I
see the truncated preview of the item's
name at the top good I'll test selecting
a category and save the item to the list
which displays the item name next to its
category and now the saved items will
remain intact across browsing sessions
multiple windows and even after closing
and reopening the browser perfect moving
forward let's give users more control
over their item list by letting them
delete items I'll ask chat gbt to allow
you users to delete items from the
shopping list permanently and that each
delete button should display a delete
icon using an icon
font okay first I need to include the
font awesome Library CSS to display the
delete icon in my popup HTML file there
we go and then I need to modify the code
in popup.js it looks like I have to
update this entire block of code that
loads and displays saved items from
storage because now it includes the code
to create delete buttons next to each
item list and run the delete
functionality when a user clicks delete
so I'll copy this full code
block then replace this block here with
all the new
code and below this code block I need to
include this new delete item function
which holds the logic to permanently
delete a saved item from Storage so I'll
grab this code snippet and add it here
in popup.js
and I even get new CSS to lay out the
item container using flexbox and style
the delete button so I'll copy the new
CSS and add it to popup
CSS and here I'll make some updates to
the button's color I'll change the
background color to a light gray and the
color to a shade of black with the value
pound 999 I also want to add a small gap
between the item name and delete button
in each item container so here in the
item container rule I'll set the Gap
property to 10 pixels
before testing the extension again I'll
update the color of the extension's name
to a dark shade of blue here in the H1
property like so I'll also select the
item links and style them with a
different color let's set it to a bright
shade of blue with this value and
increase the line height to 1.5 so that
the text doesn't look too cramped I also
want to add some base styles for the
select menu and buttons first I'll
select the button element and set its
background color let's make it blue with
this value I'll remove the button
default borders by setting the Border
property To None its text color to
white make its font weight
bold and set the user's cursor to the
pointer when they interact with the
button now I'll Target both the select
element and the button in the same CSS
rule just like that and here I'll apply
some padding let's say 5 pixels top
bottom and 10 pixels left and right and
apply rounded Corners with the Border
radius property I'll set it to four
pixels and I'll also delete this group
selector for the label select and button
because I don't want to display them as
block or on separate lines and the
bottom margin will not be
necessary okay to test all the latest
updates make sure the project folder on
your computer is up to date then in the
Chrome extensions page click the reload
icon visit a project page and launch the
extension with these changes each item
in the shopping list should have a
delete button next to it displaying a
trash can icon and they do awesome when
a user clicks the delete button the
corresponding item gets removed both
from the UI and from Storage great the
last feature I'd like to implement is to
organize all saved items based on their
category this would allow users to find
items in their list easily so I'll ask
chbt to display the saved item links as
separate lists based on their category
and to be sure that I don't miss
anything I wanted to provide the fully
updated code with detailed comments so
let's see what CBT can do with this
prompt the code in the Manifest
background.js and
popup.js file with this new code from
chat gbt just to be sure that I don't
miss anything it looks like this new
block of JavaScript adds and saves an
item to a specific list based on its
category and here it uses what's called
a loop in programming to create and
display a separate heading and list for
each category and please do take a
moment to ask chat TPT to clarify any
confusing code or concepts you've come
across I really want you to get used to
leaning on chat GPT for
help before testing the latest changes I
have some Java script challenges for you
currently in the item preview text we
see the word item in front of the name I
think this is a bit unnecessary so I'd
like you to look through the JavaScript
code and find the code that generates
the preview text and update it to remove
the word item also the preview text
should be cleared immediately after
adding the item to its category list so
I'll need you to update the JavaScript
to clear the item preview after the user
clicks the save button so pause me now
and work through these
all right hopefully that went well first
this code here is what displays the item
preview text I do see the word item here
I just want to set the text content to
the truncated title so I'll replace this
by only referencing the value of
truncated title like that next this
event listener saves items to a category
list when the user clicks the save
button so I can clear the item preview
text here with item preview. text
content and set it equal to an empty
string so if you got both of these
fantastic finally let's wrap this up by
customizing the layout of the Chrome
extension first I'll select the main
heading and the category heading all in
the same Rule and set their color to
this color value here that's in the H1
rule to apply the same color to both and
I also want to close up any extra
default space that appears below the
category or headings by setting the
bottom margin of H2 elements to zero so
now I want to enhance the select menu
and button layout so I'll start by
placing them inside a div with the class
controls just like
that and then I'll Target the controls
class in my CSS and I want to display
the controls div using flexbox with
display Flex that way both the select
element and button display on the same
line all add a 10 pixel gap between them
and create some visual space around the
top and bottom sides with margins so
first margin top let's say 15 pixels and
I'll set margin bottom to 20
pixels and since we're using flexbox I
want the select menu to stretch and take
up all available space within the
controls container so I'll Target the
select element and use a special flexbox
property called flex and set it to one
you'll see exactly how this works when
we test the extension soon and finally I
want to update the background color of
the save button on Hover the button
element is inside the div with the class
controls so I can Target just this
button with controls space button and
then colon
hover so on Hover we'll change the
background color to a lighter shade of
blue all right it's time to test our
updates so again be sure the project
folder on your computer has all the
latest files then click the extensions
reload button and visit a product page
the updated select menu and button
layout looks great notice how the select
menu stretches to take up most of the
available space and I see the preview
text with the item name only and
selecting a category then clicking save
places the item in a category list and
notice how the preview text gets cleared
after saving an item great so it looks
like we're done and let's not
underestimate the scale of what we've
accompl accomplished here you didn't
just build a Chrome extension you
created something that uses data
persistence essentially setting up a
mini database within the browser thanks
to Chrome storage that is just
wild let's take a moment to walk through
how to automate your project deployment
with GitHub and netfi this is an
integral part of building and deploying
projects and it's much simpler than it
might initially seem as you know GitHub
is your platform for Version Control and
source code management and netlify
allows you to host and deploy your
projects now that you have some projects
up on GitHub and your netlify account is
set up I'll teach you how to combine
them to automate your deployment process
using the personal homepage project we
built earlier in the section I've got my
GitHub repo all set up and here we go to
start head over to netlify.com and if
you're not logged in go ahead and log in
using your GitHub account once you're on
nfi's main dashboard go to the site
section and click add new site and
select import an existing project then
netlify asks which platform you want to
deploy with click on deploy with GitHub
having authorized netlify to access your
GitHub repositories you'll be presented
with a list of all your repositories and
you can select the one you want to
deploy if you don't immediately see it
in the list you can search for it using
this field click on the repository and
then you'll be asked to set your
deployment settings this includes
specifying the branch to deploy which is
usually main as well as any build
commands and the publish directory now
these build settings are for more
complex sites and apps that require
something called a build tool and a
special publish directory we don't need
to worry about any of these settings for
the simple personal homepage so we can
leave all of these optional Fields blank
then click deploy personal homepage
toward the bottom and netfi kicks off
the process of deploying the site it
will upload your files and give you a
unique URL to your live site
with this process netlify doesn't just
deploy your project once it's always on
the lookout for any changes you make in
your GitHub repository from here on
anytime you update your repository with
changes to your project netlify will
automatically update your live site this
way you can be sure your live site
always reflects the latest version of
the code in your GitHub repo all right
and that's all there is to automating
the deployment process with GitHub and
NFI you'll surely find it to be a
valuable tool in your building and
deployment
workflow we've reached the end of this
section and let me tell you you should
be incredibly proud of your journey so
far you've conquered more complex
projects and challenges while further
embracing the power of generative AI
we've accomplished quite a bit together
from building an interactive project
slideshow to bringing the face bump game
to life and building and launching your
very own homepage and we had a ton of
fun creating a mobile friendly Smart
Home interface and even a Chrome
extension so take a moment to Pat
yourself on the back reflect on what
you've built and learned so far and
maybe even take a short break you've
earned it now there's a lot more to
explore in the world of AI coding as
mentioned in the previous section I'll
continue adding more sections to this
course featuring new more complex
projects and I would love it if you'd
share your thoughts feedback and
suggestions about this course and any
ideas for projects you'd like to build
in future sections clicking on this
image will take you directly to the
short feedback form so I'll see you back
soon in and I look forward to hearing
from you and checking out your projects
happy
building hey again awesome Builders so
we've been on a pretty incredible
journey exploring building projects with
HTML CSS and JavaScript all with a touch
of AI assistance and now in this section
we're stepping into the fascinating
world of Firebase a tool powered by
Google to elevate your skills and build
apps that save and manage data with
Firebase you can quick connect your
projects to a database to store and
display the most upto-date information
making it accessible to anyone any time
so let's take a glimpse at the exciting
projects that are in store for you we'll
start by unraveling what Firebase is and
why it's a game changer in app
development then we'll walk through
setting up Firebase your first step
towards building Dynamic apps and we'll
get Hands-On quickly by taking the
interactive event invite project you
built and hooking it up to a Firebase
database using users will be able to add
and save messages for attendees to read
but that's just the beginning we've got
a lot more in store after that you'll
build an app called Kudos Delight that
spreads Joy with random compliments
harnessing realtime Firebase features
you'll be able to add and save kudos to
the database and randomly display them
to anyone using the app then you'll
create a fun pull app you can use with
colleagues called lunch vote to help
decide on lunch spots you'll get
hands-on experience with creating a real
time voting app and finally you'll
develop an app called Road wallet that's
perfect for Road Trippers to add manage
and split expenses as we build these
projects remember our goal Remains the
Same to help you build amazing projects
that persist data using AI assistance
and not get overwhelmed by technical
complexities we are here to push the
boundaries of your comfort zone
encouraging you to take challenges that
might seem daunting at first this
section is all about building and diving
into app development with Firebase using
AI as your guide and before we jump into
the world of Firebase please do share
your excitement let your scrimba
colleagues know that you're starting
this section in the today I will Discord
Channel you can head over to the channel
by clicking right on this image all
right so if you're ready to ignite your
projects with Firebase let's get started
and keep on building
together all right let's get going with
adding Firebase into the mix fire
Firebase is userfriendly for beginners
yet powerful enough for advanced
projects and it will be your gateway to
creating database powered realtime
projects by real time I mean
applications that can store sync and
display data between your users as soon
as it's created or updated so first a
little insight into Firebase Firebase is
currently being developed and backed by
Google and it provides a comprehensive
Suite of tools designed to help you
develop highquality apps and even games
most developers use Firebase to build
and handle what's referred to as the
backend or server side of an app that's
where all the data processing and
storage happens essentially serving as
the engine that powers the app's
functionality Now setting up and
maintaining a database can be a hassle
as you'll experience the true beauty of
Firebase lies in its Simplicity and
power making app development accessible
to everyone including those new to
coding a standout feature of Firebase is
its realtime database which which keeps
data in sync across all users and
devices whether web or mobile so this
means that when you update data in the
database like adding updating and
removing items from a shopping list app
for example all users connected to your
app receive these updates instantly
without the need for the user to reload
the app so you'll find that this feature
is particularly useful in scenarios like
messaging online polls registration apps
or collaborative tools where changes
made by one user are instantly visible
to all other users but why have me
explain the details when you can ask
chat gbt and learn more you can feed it
a simple prompt like I'm just learning
about Firebase can you explain how
firebases real-time database Works in
simple non-technical terms and how I can
use it in a web application and with
this prompt you should hopefully get a
detailed yet simple explanation with
practical examples of Firebase so here
for instance it says that you can use
Firebase as real-time database for data
storage real-time updates
synchronization AP access authentication
and more okay so next up we'll get into
setting up Firebase in a project and
start using some
features before we get building I'll
quickly show you how to get set up with
Firebase and create your very first
database using firebases real-time
database this will be your first big
step towards building Dynamic real-time
prototypes and apps make sure you have a
Google account as it's required to use
Firebase if you don't have one now is
the perfect time to create it if you're
ready first visit the Firebase website
at firebase.com then click on get
started from here you can create a new
project by clicking on the create a
project button give your project a name
this can be anything related to your app
or idea I'll name it first database then
click continue it might ask you if you
want to enable Google analytics for your
Firebase project I'll choose not to
enable it by toggling it off then click
create project then after a little while
boom you've got your Firebase project
the Firebase console is where you can
manage your apps monitor performance and
access various Firebase features once
here be sure to spend a moment exploring
as there's quite a bit to discover now
as I mentioned we're only going to be
concerned with the realtime database so
let's create our actual real-time
database here in the Firebase console
navigate to the realtime database
section under the build menu once there
click on create database first you'll
need to set a location set for where
your real-time database will be stored
so go ahead and choose a location that's
closest to you I'll stick with us
Central 1 then click next then you're
asked to set up some security rules for
example do you want to allow other users
read and write access to your database
and you have some options here for
instance you can start in what's called
locked mode to make your data private by
default but I'll go ahead and start in
test mode which allows you to experiment
more freely without strict security
rules I'll click enable and and now the
database is all set up the first thing
you want to look for is this reference
URL which is what you'll use to interact
with your real-time database now
connecting to Firebase and interacting
with your database does take some
initial configuration but no worries
because we've got the setup covered for
you scrimba offers a Firebase template
you can use to build projects using
Firebase including a basic Firebase
configuration for your web app for now
all you need to do is copy this
reference URL here in your database then
paste it as the value for this database
URL property in the scrim so go ahead
and replace what's there now with my
database reference URL our database is
currently empty so let's try adding some
data to it the Firebase template
provides a simple UI to kick things off
for you for example if I type test data
here in the text field then click push
to DB it should push the text into my
database now my test database has a
reference called things as you can see
here here in the Firebase configuration
so any data I push to it will be stored
under this reference named things okay
so now we can see the things reference
added to the database console and
expanding it shows the submitted test
data text fantastic all right let's add
some more data the real-time database
updates data synchronously or in real
time so if I click on the plus icon next
to the things reference name I can add a
new entry for example I'll add a message
key with the value you hello from
Firebase then click add notice how that
new data instantly appears here in the
app all right and there you have it
you're all set up with firebases
real-time database up next we'll dive
deeper into how to interact with your
Firebase database using
JavaScript we are going to start by
integrating Firebase into a project and
creating functionality to save and
display messages all while using chbt to
guide us through this process so let's
Jump Right In this project should look
familiar it's the interactive GIF Gayla
invite you built in a previous section
the only difference is that I've
introduced a message input field that
displays only if the user selects yes I
will be there that way they can submit
an optional fun message for all to view
and that will be done with Firebase when
users RSVP to the event and submit a
message will'll save the message to the
database then display all the messages
here in a list the message list will
update in real time highlighting
firebases real-time database
capabilities all right so I've got the
initial Firebase config all set up once
again this is using code from our
Firebase scrim template if you're
curious about it this is what's called
an import statement in JavaScript and
this Imports a function from the
Firebase app Library named initialized
app so we're able to use it from this
file and this function is used to
initialize the Firebase app with a given
configuration and Below we are bringing
in a few other functions options related
to the Firebase real-time database like
get database ref push and on value then
here in the app settings object I'm
defining the reference URL to my
Firebase realtime database and the line
below initializes the Firebase app with
the configuration defined in app
settings after initializing the app this
line retrieves the database instance
associated with the initialized Firebase
app and this creates a reference to a
specific p path in your database in this
case the messages path as you learned in
the previous scrim we can use this
reference to read from or write to the
database I went ahead and created a new
project in my Firebase console named GIF
Kayla just as we did in the previous
scrim and set up a realtime database for
it and this is my special URL to connect
to the database please do the same if
you'd like to build upon this invite
project now I don't want anyone else to
be able to access this and write to my
database so I'll show you a way to hide
this URL using what's called an
environment variable on scrimba so I'll
bring up the environment variable
dialogue window on scrimba you can
access it with a keyboard shortcut
command shift e if you're on a Mac or
windshift E for Windows and then create
a new variable called GIF Gaya DB
exactly as shown here then set its value
to my Project's database URL click add
variable and now I can access this URL
from my scrio projects using process.
EMV do the variable name so I can
replace the database URL here with
process.
env.
Gore Galore DB and that's going to work
exactly the same way while keeping my
URL hidden to learn more about
environment variables on scrimba be sure
to check out this blog post written by
the scrimba team you can click right on
this image to head over to the post all
right now let's work with chat GPT to
bring Firebase into our project there
shouldn't be a whole lot we need to do
so what I'll do is use this initial
prompt here that asks chubbt to First
evaluate my existing JavaScript code
which I'll provide here between the back
ticks then based on the code it needs to
add the Firebase real-time database to
this project it should save only the
submitted messages to the database if
the value of attendance is strictly
equal to yes or if the user selects yes
I'll be there and all of the latest
messages data needs to appear as list
items in the messages list which is this
UL element here with the class messages
and I also want chat GPT to add detailed
comments to help me understand the new
Firebase code all right so I'll copy
this prompt and feed it to chat GPT with
all of the code I have here in my
script.js file and it looks like I get
back all the code I need to add Firebase
realtime database to my event invite
project so let's quickly review this new
code I see that we're bringing in a new
function from Firebase push and it's
using push here to save each message to
the database only if the attendance
value is equal to yes so that one line
here should take care of saving the data
then it gives me this code here to
display the messages from the database
on the page now since we're working with
a real-time database we need to listen
for any changes in the database so
firebases onv Value method does just
that it data and listens for changes
each time a user submits the form with a
message new data gets added to Firebase
then this function gets called every
time data is changed at the specified
database reference so it fetches all the
data so that we can display it and this
code Loops through all the messages
return from the database and adds them
as list items inside our unordered list
all right so I'll add this new code to
my project by clicking copy code then
replacing everything in script. JS with
this new code and let's try it out I'll
first add an email address for example
Gil at
scrimba then for attendance I'll select
yes I'll be there that brings up the
message input field and I'll add a
message like I can't wait to see
everyone then click submit I get the
party on we look forward to seeing you
at the GIF Gaya confirmation message
then if I scroll down and click the show
messages button yes I see the message I
submitted I can't wait to see everyone
Gil great all right let's test out a few
more messages let's add test at
test.com then select yes I'll be there
and as the message I'll type bringing
the most epic costume click submit then
let's see great I see the new message
added to my messages list I'll add one
more message let's say I'm counting down
the days click submit and good I see the
message appear in the list list now if I
have a look at my database in the
Firebase console I can see all of the
submitted messages under the messages
reference awesome so now even when a
user refreshes the app or closes the
browser window then revisits it they'll
still be able to see all of the messages
on the page all right so you learn how
to integrate Firebase into an existing
project and these are pretty much the
steps to follow for most projects you
want to connect to the real-time
database so nice work let's keep going
all right now we're going to spread some
positivity and Delight by building quite
the unique web app a compliment
generator you can use to brighten
someone's day with a simple kind message
and we'll use Firebase with chat gbt to
make this happen our compliment
generator is named Kudos delight and it
will randomly select compliments or
Kudos from a database and display them
to users but that's not all users can
also submit their own compliments making
our generator a a constantly evolving
pool of positivity so we'll get to do a
little random data retrieval with
Firebase which should be fun all right
first if you want to run this project
for yourself you'll need to create a new
project in Firebase for the compliment
generator project and set up a real-time
database for it just like I've shown you
in previous projects now I've done all
that and saved my database URL as an
environment variable on scrimba named
Kudos DB just like this and I've also
set up a simple yet inviting U bu for
our compliment generator so you won't
have to worry about the HTML styling and
basic JavaScript functionality so let's
quickly go over the HTML for the app as
you can see here in the body I have a
div with a class container and within
that we have an H1 with the app's name
and then a paragraph to display all the
compliments and below the paragraph We
have a button to fetch all the
compliments from the database and then
we have a toggle button that when
clicked shows and hides the form to
submit kudos to the
database over in the JavaScript I have
all the initial Firebase configuration
as you've seen before with a reference
named compliments then I'm selecting
some page elements like the button
compliment display and form elements and
assigning them to variables and finally
a toggle form event listener to show and
hide the Kudo submission form and set
the toggle button text based on whether
the form is hidden or not so that's how
changing the button text from add kudos
to hide form for example and showing and
hiding the form all right it's time to
set up our Firebase project you should
have created a new project in the
Firebase console and set up the
real-time database for it so I'm going
to ask you to work on the first part of
this on your own with a challenge we
want to let users contribute kudos to
the app via the form and the database so
you are going to use the provided prompt
to program the submission form to add
new complement to the database let's
have a look at the prompt here in
prompt. MD this prompt lets the AI know
that you'd like to build a compliment
generator that randomly selects
compliments from a Firebase real-time
database and display them to users and
first it needs to program the submission
form to let users add new compliments to
the database and that it should use your
Firebase config and existing project
code as a reference so you'll need to
provide all of the code here in index.js
between the triple back ticks we also
want detailed comments added to the new
code to help us understand it all right
so give this challenge a go now and I'll
catch up with you when you're done to go
over this first part
together okay hopefully you were able to
do that now I'll give it a whirl keep in
mind that the solution you got was most
likely different than mine and that's
totally fine as long as you got it to
work in a similar way all right so I'll
copy my prompt here and feed it to chat
GPT T including all of my starter code
from
index.js all right good so I got back
all of the code for adding new
complements to the Firebase realtime
database so what I'll do is copy this
function to handle form submissions from
the provided code snippit and paste it
in
index.js all right let's go over this
new code so we have an event listener
added to the compliment form to handle
form submissions when the form is
submitted we prevent the default form
submission Behavior here with e. prevent
default then we get the value from the
input field and trim it this trim method
cleans up the submission by removing any
leading and trailing spaces tabs or line
braks from the string if necessary then
if there is a new complement or if the
value of new complement is not an empty
string it pushes the string to the
Firebase database as a new complement
and then after successful submission we
clear the input Fe field then hide the
submission form by setting its class to
Hidden and then update the button text
accordingly so in this case it's setting
the button text to add
Kudos finally in any case of Errors
during the submission process an error
message is logged to the console here in
the catch method so this catches any
errors then displays them in the console
here with console. a all right I'll test
this out by submitting a Kudo here let's
say your jokes are truly hilarious
then click submit and checking my
database in the console does in fact
show that my compliment was submitted
great so there's officially some
communication between my project and the
database now this was just a test
submission so I'll delete this from my
Firebase database because soon I'll want
to test what the app displays when there
are no compliments in the
database all right so now let's work on
the most important part of our project
fetching compliments from the Firebase
database and displaying them on the page
for that I'll add a new prompt here to
my promptmd file this prompt asks the AI
to write the functionality that gets the
compliments data from Firebase then
displays a random compliment to the user
each time they click the generate
button and you'll do this with a
challenge I want you to use chubbt by
feeding it this prompt to add the
JavaScript to connect the generate
button to Firebase retrieve the
compliments and display one random
compliment to the user so go ahead and
work through this challenge now and when
you're done join me back to go over it
together all right hopefully you were
able to make this happen now I'll give
it a go I'll copy this prompt then paste
it into chat gbt and good it looks like
I get back the code snippet to fetch
compliments from the Firebase database
so I'll copy this new code and paste it
here in
index.js all right let's quickly go over
it
in this new code we're defining a new
function called Fetch compliments that
will fetch the complement or Kudos data
from Firebase inside the function it's
using a function from Firebase called
get to retrieve data from the complement
ref then if data exists we convert it
into an array and select a random
complement from the array so that's what
all of this code here is doing and it's
also updating the content of the
complement display element on the page
with the randomly selected compliment
then we're saying else if no compliments
exist then set the text content of the
compliment display to no compliments
available and just like the earlier code
in case of any errors during the
fetching process an airror message is
logged to the console here with this
catch method and there's also a click
event listener for the generate button
that calls the fetch compliments
function when the button is clicked all
right let's test it out I'll first try
clicking the generate button without any
Kudos in the database and it says no
compliments available and that's correct
this text is being generated with this
line of code here so I'll make it more
on brand and update it to say no Kudos
available okay now I'll submit audo
using the form again let's have it say
your jokes are truly
hilarious click submit now I'll try
clicking generate a Kudo and great there
it is I'll submit a few more to test the
randomness
I'll say you are smarter than my
smartphone submit it then how about
you're the human version of a high
five submit that and one more your ideas
are always so
Innovative all right let's try
generating random Kudos and perfect we
are indeed starting to Generate random
Kudos from our
database the final thing I'll do is give
the user some visual Fe feedback once
they've submitted their Kudos and I'll
use this prompt for
that it says to add the necessary code
to display a success message once the
user submits a compliment to the
database and that the message should
disappear after 3 seconds all right so
let me feed this prompt to chat PT and I
get back the new code for displaying a
success message when the user submits a
compliment to the database so first it's
selecting an HTML element with the the
ID success message which will be used to
display the success message so I'll copy
this line from the code snippet and
paste it in index.js where I'm selecting
all of my page
elements and Below it's defining a new
function called show success message so
I'll copy this function from the code
snibbit and add it to my code here in
index.js this function sets the display
style property of the success message
element to block to make it visible and
it uses a function in JavaScript called
set timeout to hide the success message
after 3 seconds by setting the display
style property to none and inside the
form submission event listener after
successfully adding a compliment to the
database it's calling the show success
message function to display the success
message for 3 seconds so I'll copy this
function call from the code snippet then
add it to my compliment form event
listener right here in this then method
now I've already included a paragraph
element in my HTML for the success text
notice how it's initially hidden by
setting an inline display style To None
all right so all that's left is trying
it out let's first check if generating
audo still works and it does so now I'll
try submitting a Kudo let's just say
you're the coolest click submit and
fantastic the success message displays
for about 3 seconds then it disappears
I'll add another Kudo for good measure
let's say you have an amazing way with
words all right
perfect so congrats on building your
very own compliment generator you've
just built something that not only
teaches you valuable coding skills but
also has the power to spread positivity
so be sure to share your Kudos Delight
app on social media and with the scriba
community to show the world what you've
built using a
database
it's Friday afternoon atw workk and
there you are again in that endless
where should we eat for lunch debate
with your co-workers it's a common
dilemma in every workplace well it's
time to say goodbye to all those lengthy
discussions and indecisions because
we're going to build something that's
not only fun but also incredibly
practical a lunch break poll app called
lunch vote this app will not only make
deciding where to go for lunch easier
but also give you the opportunity to
keep building realtime web apps once
again we'll use Firebase for real-time
data handling and chat gbt for any
coding queries we might have in the
lunch vote app users can add their
favorite lunch spots to a list then the
team can vote on where they'd like to go
so we're going to focus on realtime vote
tallying and allowing everyone to see
the poll evolve as votes are cast so
let's jump in and get started I've
already set us up with our application
main structure this is all chat gbt
generated and if you're curious I fed
chat gbt this prompt to create the
initial HTML CSS and JavaScript code in
the HTML we have a form with an input
field for adding lunch places and a
submit button and below a div for
displaying the top lunch vote and a list
for displaying each lunch place as usual
in the JavaScript we have the initial
Firebase configuration and I've created
a reference to a specific location in
the Firebase database named places and
as usual that's creating using firebases
ref method and Below we are prepared to
interact with the web page by obtaining
references to various elements like the
form and input field and the elements
that will be used for displaying and
interacting with data from the Firebase
database now we're only going to focus
on the Firebase code in this project so
first things first you'll need to set up
a new Firebase project and create a
real-time database I've already done
that and stored the database URL in a
scrimba environment variable named lunch
vote DB so go ahead and do that now okay
so with our front end ready it's time to
integrate Firebase we'll need to include
some JavaScript that will push new lunch
places to fireb and fetch them for
display most importantly we'll need to
implement realtime vote tallying where
vote counts update once they're clicked
that way everyone can see the most
popular choices as votes come
in all right so I'll kick things off
with this prompt that lets chat GPT know
that I'm building an app called lunch
vote to add lunch places display them
and allow users to vote I want it to
store each lunch place in Firebase and
that users cast a vote by clicking on a
lunch place the vote counts should
update in real time using firebases real
real time database and as usual I wanted
to evaluate and use my Firebase
configuration and existing project code
as a reference to get started like
before I'll include my JavaScript
between the triple btics and naturally I
wanted to add detailed comments to the
new code to help me understand it all
right so let's feed this to chat upbt
now normally I've been using chat upbt
3.5 for our projects but I'll need to
step up my game with chat GPT 4 why the
change well GPT 3.5 has shown some
compatibility issues with our project's
needs according to its latest training
data for Firebase specifically so in
this case chat gp4 is more Adept at
handling and parsing this code base and
what we need for the lunch vote app all
right so I'll add my prompt here and I
get back a lot of new code and it's code
that pushes a new lunch place to
Firebase when the form is submitted then
listens for changes in the Firebase
database and updates the UI and it's
implementing a voting mechanism there's
quite a bit of code here so so I'll copy
the entire JavaScript snippet and
replace everything in my index.js file
with the new
code there we go so let's go over the
new code when the user submits the form
this event listener triggers and this if
statement it pushes a new place with the
name and an initial vote count of zero
to Firebase then it clears the input
field after submission we also have a
real-time data listener firebases onv
value function con constantly listens
for changes in the places Firebase
reference so whenever a change occurs
like a new place is added or votes are
updated it updates the UI and with this
code when a user clicks on a list item
or place it triggers a vote increment
for that specific place in Firebase it's
bringing in a new function from Firebase
called update to increment the vote
count and it looks like here the app
tracks and updates which place has the
highest vote and then this code displays
the leading place on the page overall
this code ensures that your apps UI is
always in sync with your Firebase
database in real time providing a
dynamic and interactive user experience
all right let's try it I'll add a lunch
Place Like Big Kahuna Burger I hear
they've got some tasty burgers and I'll
add another
place there we go all right I'll click
to vote for Big Kahuna bger and good I
see the vote count update to one and the
leading Place update to bikun burer with
one vote and if we have a look at our
database we can see the data being
stored under the places reference each
place has a name and vote property and
currently Big Kahuna Burger is set to
one so it looks like our app is
successfully updating and retrieving
vote counts in Firebase instantly that
way everyone can see the most popular
choices as votes come in now currently
it seems like anyone can vote as many
times as they want for example I can
keep clicking on a place and the vote
count keeps going up so let's figure out
how to allow users to vote only once and
by that I mean let's have chat GPT
figure this out for us so I'll use this
prompt here that says add the code to
allow a user only to vote once and that
users should also be able to change
their vote so I'll feed this prompt to
chat gbt and in its reply it says that
to implement the feature where a user
can only vote once but can change their
vote we need to track which place a user
has voted for and that can be done by
storing the user's vote in the local
storage of the browser well that's
pretty clever local storage is a browser
feature that allows a site to store some
data in the browser which it can use
again and again when you revisit the
site now it looks like quite a bit of
code was updated so thankfully it gives
me the entire JavaScript code to copy
into my project so I'll copy everything
by clicking copy code and then replacing
everything in my index.js file with this
new code okay let's go over the changes
so here I'm seeing this new function
named update user vote which uses the
browser's local storage to remember the
user's current vote this is a simple way
to track votes without requiring user
authentication for example and this
function handles changing the user's
vote it decreases the vote count for the
previous Choice as we can see here in
this if statement it looks like it's
using firebases update function to
update only the value of a place's vote
property in the database so it's
decreasing it here by one if the vote
count is greater than
zero now this code below increases the
vote count for the new vote so it's also
using firebases update function to
increase the vote count here and it's
updating it in the browser's local
storage and it looks like there's also
added Logic for the vote changing so
here with this code when a user clicks
on a list item it checks if the user is
is changing their vote here in this if
statement if so it updates the vote both
in Firebase and in the local storage by
running this update user vote function
we just looked at all right looks like
those are all the changes so let's test
this first I'll reset the database by
deleting all of the lunch places there
we go I'll add a couple of new lunch
places all right so now if I try voting
I see that I can only vote vote for one
place so I keep trying to vote for good
burger by clicking on it but it doesn't
allow me to increase the vote count now
if I click to vote for The Other Place
notice how my vote switches excellent in
fact I have this app open right now in
multiple browsers so if I vote on a
lunch place you can see it update here
in the app in real time so check it
out hey it looks like Jack Rabbit Slims
won they do have some pretty good $5
milkshakes
finally how about we add a feature where
a user can delete the poll once a place
has been chosen for that I'll use this
prompt here that says add a delete poll
button at the bottom which clears the
database and resets the poll and to
display the delete button only after a
poll gets created all right so here you
go chat GPT do your thing and here's all
the new code so first I need to add this
delete pull button to my HTML I'll go
ahead and copy it then paste it in my
HTML just below the places list notice
how the button is initially hidden with
its display property set To None next
I'll modify my JavaScript to include the
logic for showing the button handling
the click event and resetting the poll
I'll copy this line of code here that
targets that delete button in my HTML
and include the variable up here where
I'm targeting all of my page elements
right there and in the new JavaScript we
have this reset poll function so I'll go
ahead and copy that and add it to my
code let's just paste it right here
below my variables so when this delete
pull button gets clicked we're going to
call this function to clear the Firebase
database where the polls are stored
that's being done right here with this
set method and then it's going to clear
the leading Place display as well as the
list of places and hide the delete
button and it looks like we have a new
if else statement we need to add to our
on value function so I'll copy that from
the code snippet then scroll down to my
on value function where I'm listening
for realtime updates from Firebase right
here and I'll just paste in the new if
else statement at the top remember onv
value is a listener for the Firebase
database it checks if any polls exist
and updates the visibility of the delete
button accordingly so for example this
script here checks if there are any
polls in the database base if poles are
present it shows the delete button by
setting its display style to block
otherwise the button remains hidden with
its display style set To None finally
I'll copy this event listener here for
the delete button and paste it in my
code right at the bottom so when the
delete button gets clicked it calls the
reset pull function to reset the poll
and remember that is this function here
that we just added to our code okay so
let's test this out once again I'll
clear my database so I can see if the
delete pull button gets hidden I just
did that in my Firebase console and good
I no longer see lunch places in the app
so because my database is empty we are
not seeing the delete poll button just
yet but I'll add a place to start a
poll and good the delete poll button
appears I'll add a couple more
places and there we go now to me the
button feels a bit misaligned I want to
align it Center on the page so I can
quickly do that with a CSS adjustment
this rule here is targeting the delete
pull button and you've learned in
previous projects that you can Center a
line and element on the page using
margin and the value auto so I'll
replace this margin top property here
with the margin shorthand and I'll keep
the 20 pixels of top margin then I'll
set the left and right margin values
here to Auto and the bottom margin value
to zero and there we go our button is
now perfectly centered aligned I'll
click to vote on a lunch place we see
the vote count change and the leading
Place change up top now clicking the
delete poll button should delete the
lunch places from the app so I'll try
that and I get an error it says that set
is not defined hm take a moment to have
a look through index.js and see if you
can figure out how to fix
this okay so this fix shouldn't be too
bad I see that the reference error is
set is not defined so here in this reset
pole function we are using firebases set
function to reset the poll when the
button gets clicked so I'll have a look
at where we are importing the functions
from Firebase and I do not see that
we're importing the set function so
presumably all I need to do here is
include the set function and now I'll
try clicking delete poll and great all
the lunch places get deleted from the
app so it looks like we're done here now
I want you to pause me for a and take
the time to add some places cast your
votes and watch how the application
responds in real
time okay great so now maybe even think
about ways to extend the app with more
features for example what happens when
there's a tie between two or more lunch
places and congrats you've just built a
realtime lunch break pull app showcasing
the power of Firebase in creating
Dynamic user interactive web apps so
well done let's move on to our final
project you're on a road trip with
friends the journey is epic but tracking
who paid for gas snacks and other stuff
is turning into a chaotic mess sound
familiar well it's time to bring Clarity
and ease to your adventures we about to
build the road Wallet app the ultimate
solution for managing group travel
expenses without the headaches Road
wallet provides a realtime overview of
expenses balances and settles the who
paid for what debate instantly so here's
what our app will feature Travelers will
be able to log various expenses
categorized into food gas accommodation
sightseeing and more and you can add
travelers to split costs and display
each person's share you'll also be able
to review your expenses here under
expense history and here you can also
easily delete expenses in case of errors
or changes and the app will use the data
from Firebase to do realtime
calculations to to show how much each
traveler owes in real time as expenses
are added I've provided all of the
starter code from the app which will
take a look at in just a bit and here's
what the road Wallet app is looking like
so far I can click manage travelers to
add travelers to the app and they get
displayed below you can select an
expense here from the category menu for
example gas and set the amount to let's
say $100 click at expense and see it
listed under expense history I can add
another expense like food and just say
$200 for example and now our expense
total is $300 and if we click manage
Travelers we can see that both Gil and
Tom each owe
$150 now this isn't connected to
Firebase just yet so if I refresh the
app all my expenses and traveler data is
reset so again to ensure seamless
collaboration and real-time updates we
are going to connect Road wallet to fire
firebases real-time database with the
help of chat gbt we're going to persist
the expense in traveler data to Firebase
so that when a traveler or expense gets
added or updated the changes will be
saved to the Firebase database in this
project we're starting with more
pre-written code than usual and like the
previous project I use chat GPT to help
me generate all of the code the goal in
this Grim is to explore how chat gbt can
effectively interact with modify and
enhance a sub substantial existing
codebase like ours so as usual in the
JavaScript we have the initial Firebase
configuration and here I have a
reference to a specific location in the
Firebase database named Road wallet I
created a new project in Firebase and
set up a real-time database for it and I
saved the databases reference URL in a
scrimba variable named Road wallet DB so
go ahead and do that now if you want to
work on this project all right so below
we are retrieving all of the necessary
elements for manipulation for example
the expense form motor window buttons
and more and then we have two arrays
here to store expenses and traveler data
and below that we have our event
listeners that open and close the
traveler modal window when the open or
close button is clicked and this event
listener here closes the modal window if
the user clicks outside of it like so
and here's the event listener for the
expense form submission and the event
listener for adding a traveler now below
are all of the functions that handle
logic such as managing expenses and
traveler's data as well as keeping track
of the total expenses amount and the
amount owed by each traveler and
displaying them in the app if needed I
recommend that you pause me and take a
moment to review this code before moving
on okay so I'm going to use this prompt
here to connect my app to Firebase The
Prompt will let cat GPT know that I've
buil built the front end for an app
which does the following and it lists
its features like logging travel
expenses under categories adding
travelers to split costs than displaying
each person's share and the app will
show how much each traveler owes in real
time as expenses are added and it will
list and delete expenses so we want chat
gbt to write the code to store and
manage the apps traveler and expense
data using firebases realtime database
and like we've done in previous projects
I want chat GPT to use my Firebase
configuration and existing project code
as a reference to get started so I will
be providing all of the code from
index.js here between the triple back
ticks and I want it to give me back the
entire JavaScript code with detailed
comments to help me understand it all
right so let's paste this code into chat
gbt including all of my code from
index.js and once again I'm going to
leverage the power and the latest
knowledge and Firebase training data of
chat GPT 4 for that it will be much more
Adept at handling what we need need for
Road wallet and it looks like I get back
a lot of changes now to avoid any
confusion with the new code or the
possibility of leaving out code and
breaking my app I'll ask chubbt to
please give me the complete Javascript
file because it looks like it's leaving
out some of my existing code so this way
I'll be able to just replace my existing
code with all of the updated code all
right there is the complete Javascript
file with the Firebase integration so
I'll copy it from chat gbt and then
replace everything in index.js with this
new
code wow this is a lot of code so let's
spend some time going over it the new
code integrates firebases real-time
database with my existing logic enabling
the app to store and manage data in the
real-time database and it also covers
all the functionalities for adding
deleting and displaying expenses and
travelers in the new code it looks like
we're bringing in some new functions
from Firebase remove and set and we have
some new references expenses ra and
travelers RA are references to specific
paths in the Firebase database where
expenses and travelers data will be
stored I also noticed that the handle
new expense and handle new traveler
functions now include logic to save new
expenses and travelers to Firebase using
the push and set methods as you can see
here and these delete expense and remove
traveler functions remove items from
Firebase using their unique
IDs and cool I see that it included on
value listeners for expenses ra and
travelers ref to automatically update
our local expenses and travelers array
when there's a change in the Firebase
database and I see that the add expense
to list and add traveler to list
functions have been modified to include
the unique ID of each traveler or
expense which is necessary for deletion
operations all right as usual if you
have any questions about this code you
can always ask the AI to explain the
parts of the code that you don't quite
understand yet and if that's a lot right
now that's completely normal remember
the focus here is to push the limits
with all of the ways AI can contribute
to our code and projects all right so
let's test it out by adding some data
and playing around with the features we
also want to ensure that everything
syncs perfectly with Firebase and that
our calculations are accurate so first
I'll click manage travelers to open up
the motal window and add Travelers let's
say Gil Tom raid and Bob that sounds
like a fun road
trip okay let's add some expenses first
I'll select the food category and let's
say $500 click add expense and there we
go we see food listed in the expense
history so if I click to manage The
Travelers we see that each person owes
$125 and that's correct okay let's add
more expenses naturally we'll need to
pay for gas so let's say
250 there we see gas in the expense
history and each person now owes
$187.50 all right let's see we'll need
some accommodations so that'll be about
$600 there we go and our traveler data
updated accordingly good if I delete an
expense let's say gas for example now
each person owes
$275 and if for some reason someone
drops out like me and ooh now each
person owes about
$367 sorry about that all right now
looking at the data in my Firebase
console I can see all of the data saved
under expenses and travelers for example
but it looks like we might not need this
amount Ed property in the database
notice how they are all set to zero so
it seems like the code is using the
expenses data from the database to
generate the amount owed by each person
and that's completely fine for this
first go at the app so since we don't
need the amount owed property saved to
the database we can remove the Firebase
code here that is setting that
property and that's being done here in
the handle new traveler function so here
in the set method we can remove the
amount Ed property that way it's just
setting or saving the new traveler name
to Firebase and everything should work
work exactly the same way and it does so
I'm back in the road trip let's welcome
pair to the road trip and good the
amount owed still updates accordingly
for each person I'll even delete some
expenses and test that it also updates
the amount owed for example say goodbye
to food and it does let's say food is
now
$700 and that worked the total expenses
is $1,300 and each person owes
$260 all right so now I'll test
refreshing the app enti IR L and all of
my road wallet data should be present
and it is fantastic hey so
congratulations on building Road wallet
you've navigated a complex codebase
implemented realtime data handling and
created a solution that makes travel
easier and more enjoyable for everyone
involved so what I want you to do now is
think about how you might transform the
app into a mobile friendly app that
users can install on their device and
conveniently launch from their home
screen you learn how to do just that in
the previous section so follow those
steps to make it happen and be sure to
share your app and show everyone what
you've built I'll see you in the next
scrim to wrap things
up wow what a great ride this has been
as we wrap up this section take a moment
to reflect on your achievements you've
not only embraced the power of Firebase
but also built some pretty fantastic
real-time datadriven applications you
connected your interactive gift Gaya
invitation to a realtime database to to
save and display messages then ventured
through the creation of the compliment
generator spreading Joy with every click
and we navigated the collaborative world
of decision-making with the lunch vote
app and tackled the Practical yet
challenging Road Wallet app making every
road trip more organized and fun these
projects weren't just about coding they
were about bringing ideas to life and
solving real world problems with a
database you've come a long way so it's
time to give yourself a well-deserved
pat on the back and treat yourself every
line of code you wrote and every problem
you solved has brought you one step
closer to becoming a more proficient and
confident Builder so keep experimenting
keep building and most importantly keep
enjoying every step of your building
Journey thanks and happy building